Well. Well, well go to your mom's house.
Christina.
Vincent,
thank you for gracing us with
your presence today. My pleasure.
Thank you for having me. It's
been a while. It has been.
You're the second guest we've had
in three years. Whoa. That's crazy.
Stop doing guest a long time ago.
But then now we have this setup where
like we should bring gas back. Yeah.
Why not? Why not? Fuck it. Yeah. It's
fun. You, we told you we had the uh,
the water, someone ea
here last week. Yeah. Uh,
some people thought it was a joke and they
wrote in like, Hey, uh, I turned it off.
I thought that bit was going
kind of on that a bit. Well,
cause we play boring cliffs on the show
sometimes. Yeah. And people are like,
that was the longest boring clip.
Yeah. Oh, that's hilarious. Yeah.
When there's too many laughs, we'll be
like, let's boil it down a little bit.
He'll play something boring and
they're like, it's a long board.
Got a peaks and valleys. Yeah. Lower
the expectations. Slam at home. Yeah.
So we had a bunch of people,
but some people were,
I would say most people were fascinated.
I was fucking fascinating.
I had no idea until I walked in here that
that was a real thing. Yeah. And He um,
he, he works at Patina, which
is a restaurant downtown.
I don't know if you've been there, but
he created a water menu there. Yeah.
So when people go, come on and you're
like, yeah, can I have, you know,
you ordered and he's like to drink
and you go, I'll just have water.
He'll be like, I'll be right back. And
then it's a water menu, so you get to, he,
he basically does what we were
telling you. But you know,
like a beautiful presentation and people
start, if I went out to a restaurant,
they had a water menu. I,
it depends on how high am,
if I was really high and be
like, what's going on? Yeah.
But if I was so bad I was like,
fuck you. I'm a little bit worse.
But if you're really high you might
be like bringing on of everything.
Let me try all this. You try your
water, man. Yeah. Um, all right.
We have an opening clip before we just
think before we get into our irregular as,
this is how we open our shows. So we'll
play our clip and then we'll get into it.
Here we go.
Around June the 21st when a Skype,
when trance was skyping with me,
uh, Brent spiner said, hey, you,
who Taran so something's going on
with Nancy McCaughan Hayes Penis.
And what was happening was all of my
men's penises were being attacked.
Nope.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina
courses.
Oh,
I know.
What's this, Bro? What do you mean?
I can be, this is, what is she talking
about? Rational. What's the deal?
There's one forest Whitaker I going on.
Yeah.
And there's also, there's something
about crazy that does something to your,
you know,
the way you see eyes.
And you could tell like if you're
talking to her in person, you'd be like,
even if he didn't say crazy peanut shit,
you'd be like, something's up with her.
Oh, yeah. Well, it's the, the, the gays
that doesn't break. That's right. Yeah.
The unknown. Blanking. Yeah. Yeah. It's a
real indicator and sanded. It does a lot.
Yeah.
There was a very serious, now where in
the computer system at Church of Gail,
it caused all the mandatory to gale to
cause them to have all sorts of penis
afflictions.
It's very painful.
Church of Gail, I think that's her own
church. Church of gale. Oh yeah. I think.
Why does she think it has to
do with Matthew mcconaughey?
I Dunno, but she goes on
or deal with the penises lasted for
a least a good week in that juice.
Like from June 21st of June 28th they
were just having this ordeal with penises
because of Jesuit trigger programming
on the Church of Gail computers.
They spent a lot of time in
sick bay. Uh, actively had them.
Now I know at that point,
well like mad vagina. Matthew,
his penis went inward.
I think it's funny that she,
she thinks that the Jesuits
are targeting are usually,
you don't hear them mention the you.
It's a very affable, they're fun. Yeah.
That was really highly educated
college. Yeah. They like to drink.
They like to party.
They're not really into this stuff.
You know what's interesting about her,
if you didn't know any better,
like if you spoke a different
language and you listened to her talk,
he'd be like, well, she seems
to totally rational. Yeah.
She's sitting there calmly,
she's not, she's moving too much. You
maybe she's an expert and like, right.
Ancient civilization. How a lot of cons
happen. I must, I'm assuming, you know,
like I was watching that
Bernie Madoff movie,
the new one is really good with the
Niro and Michelle Pfeiffer find what's
called wizard of lies.
And they were just talking about how
like his greatest skill was just people
manipulating and he had this
crazy thing where he was,
that's the craziest part of
was he was already successful.
He was a really well off,
was a multimillionaire and he's still,
you know,
uh,
design this Ponzi scheme to extract so
much more out of people. And they said,
you know,
because his reputation was such,
and he was just knew how to talk to
people. They're just handing over money,
man in it to fuck people over.
Like for the stuff,
the fun reel of screwing
people over all of it. Yes.
It's a real super addicted to the cash.
There's a great interview with him on
radio lab and it's really interesting
because they have to
interview him from jail.
And so when you call someone in jail,
you can only talk
to them for 15 minutes and then you have
to wait off the phone for 15 minutes
for them to come back on.
And then 15 minutes again.
So they're interviewing this guy and these
15 minute chunks and it just cuts off
at 15 minutes and they
asked to wait and it,
but he's describing this waiting and
then as time went on he talks to made off
more and more. It gets more and
more comfortable. But the, the,
the crazy thing about him is the
complete total lack of empathy.
None is no empathy towards the people
you fucked over people that killed
themselves. Like there was a bunch
of people that just, one guy,
which was really fascinating.
He was worth $9 billion and Bernie was
telling him that he had to give seven of
it back. He called the guy up, he goes,
look, the CEG is up. Everybody knows.
And apparently he,
he thinks,
or at least his rationale
was that all these people,
like the big high roller guys, they
knew that they were ripping people off.
They knew that there was no way
you could always make money,
that there was always
going to be fluctuation.
But like even in like
the way they describe it,
I don't really necessarily
understand finances that much,
but the way they were describing it is
that in like every single move they made,
this one guy wanted to make money
every single, like there was never,
you kid couldn't ever show any losses
at all or this guy would freak out.
And he had like, again,
$7 billion in the mix.
That's insane. Yeah. Yeah. He, um,
he said in an interview that when they
were like asking them about, you know,
you destroy it all these people
lives. He was like, yeah,
what about their culpability in all of
this? Like, what? And he's like, well,
you know, I mean, they, they, they have
some responsibility and they're like,
you stole from them. He's like, yeah, but
they fucking gave me the money, you know?
Yeah. His thing was like, these people,
these people are, they're not starving.
That's what his thing. We're not talking
about people in Africa, you know,
we're not talking about starving.
Villagers were just talking about people.
His own son killed himself.
One of son killed himself.
This guy killed himself that we
talking about the $9 billion guy.
He killed himself because he won.
They wanted them to give back seven.
She's like, I can't
live with to fuck that.
That's so funny. People's
relationship with money. There was a,
I forget it was actually, you might not
have killed himself. Might have drowned.
Oh really? Yeah, it might not. It
might just took too many drugs,
but there was a New York Knick,
I forget his name,
and they were interviewing him about, you
know, these NBA contracts are bananas.
It's fully guaranteed. It's one of the
leagues that has fully guaranteed money.
So not like the NFL where it's
like you have this much guaranteed.
The rest of that, you're not
getting that shit. So NBA, whatever.
Then you know there's salary caps and
he played out one of his contracts and
they're like,
we want to keep you but we can't give
you like top end money so you're going to
get 9 million for next year. And then
his first interview with the press,
he was like, I mean, you know it's going
to be tough, but I'll see what I know.
I'll try to make it happen.
And they're like,
you're going to be tough to survive
on that. And he was like pretty much,
I mean I have a family
man perspective, man.
People get crazy. Yeah,
well yeah,
because
going out, I mean, you know,
I follow all these kids on
Instagram like Cameron Dallas.
Do you know who that is? No, he's
like the sh the millennial hot shit.
He's like this hot 18 year old
boy and he and his friends,
they just enter this business, you're
going to die. They don't have talent.
They're just like cute boys on Instagram.
And they do these meet and greets where
they meet like gaggles just auditoriums
theaters full of like tween pre adolescent
girls and their parents and they
hugged them and take like chased
pictures and millionaires Maley,
he's on a dolce and Gabbana I
know skillset. None. No talent.
They follow them on Instagram
and cute teen boys. Yeah. Yes.
Hade to meet the people. It's,
it's fascinating. So there's a,
there's a Netflix show called
uh, is it chasing camera? Yeah.
And I'm obsessed with it now.
The thing is that they,
they're spending their money like crazy
cause I follow them on Instagram and
every week it's like, here's my new
Ferrari, here's the new Lamborghini,
I'm leasing, here's the new house
I'm renting. And you're like,
you're not even buying.
Yeah,
I'll buy that house, dude. Get some
equity on it. Yeah, they're just 18.
Yes.
But they're also like,
I think they don't realize that that
window of cute girls that were being cute
and the girls being like, ah,
it's you is very limited. Yeah.
Everybody says that about Kim
Kardashian. Yeah, I guess so. Right.
But they say they keep growing new ones.
You know what I'm saying? It's like, yeah,
like in a different strokes and they
added like the red haired kid to make the
show appealing.
Again,
talking about the chase
or the Kardashians. The
Kardashians. So they keep the,
so now Kylie's being groomed to,
that's what keeps it going.
It's because I think it's all about
Kim. Really? Yeah, it's Kim and she is.
Even though there's about her,
there's a real mother mother like
Chris Kim is like the matriarch of the,
did you guys cover her fake ass
kick ass photos from Mexico? No,
I think I saw some of them.
Oh well here's the deal.
They always hire their own Paparazzi and
the Paparazzi pretends to just casually
catch them taking pictures.
But in Mexico there was real Paparazzi
waiting along with their fake Paparazzi.
So they're fake.
Paparazzi takes the photos and then they
edit them and they smooth out all the
cellulite and all this whole shit
doesn't have it. I mean, yeah,
I mean it's normal human part of zoom,
especially if you're a big fat ass
like that. It's made of fat, but it's,
it's a fake fat ass and it's
super obvious in the new pictures.
Look at the Greenlee. Yeah.
Get your life. Got Real one.
Like look at the ones on the left.
Like where in life would you app?
That's a tumor, right? Right,
right. That's a full diaper. Yeah.
Diaper and internal is,
yeah.
I mean your legs are so scrawny and
then she has this giant enormous,
but so what they would do with Photoshop
is stretch out the thigh to meet the
ass. So it's, it doesn't look so
fucking so was this like a yeah,
that one doctored.
We doctored ones and make it look less.
Right. The real one. It just
looks like chess. Hilarious.
It's like, uh, it's just, uh,
like that. What the fuck is that? What
is that? What do you do in your assets?
So rose,
it's so crazy,
but it's so nuts that someone
wants to do that to their body.
Like she's stuffing something in there.
I don't know what it is,
but there's no way in nature you would
have those skinny ass legs like that,
that are total unathletic legs.
The legs of someone who doesn't work out.
Yeah, exactly right. There's no muscle
at all and nothing. I mean, I mean,
she maybe works out a little
bit like we go to scrawny arms,
but she's not an athletic person.
You haven't asked like that.
You should be able to jump
over the moon. Right, right.
That's someone who can do hurdles,
but she's kind of good weight,
but she looks good everywhere else. These
are all Photoshop. Let me, it's hard.
I mean, it's hard to say. Everything is
fake. I mean, when you say she looks good,
it's like, yeah, she's not fat.
Right. But yeah, but that's it.
Everything else is just, all surgeries
definitely is a fake as fuck.
Yeah. I mean that's her whole
thing. She's known for her ass.
Like Jennifer Lopez
has a legit Latina ass.
Like that's her real ass. Her legs
match that ass. Take a picture of,
you'll go get me a Jennifer Lopez, his
ass. She's got those big fic mommy thighs.
Yeah, I can dig ass. That's all
there. That's real. You know,
you look at that and go,
Ooh baby. Yeah, that's real.
That's a real big juicy ass girl.
Yeah.
See how her thighs are so thick. They
eat the ass. That's all proportion. Yeah,
100% that's what it's supposed to
look like. She's a dancer. Classy.
I'm on, but yeah, you're right.
That's dancing all fucking day.
All our lives a week. Yeah.
That's an athlete's ass.
That's a girl who can, yeah,
you do. That's a girl who can bounce
around and move and you know, I mean,
can you imagine if you had to watch
Kim Kardashian dance on the stage,
you know those little spindly
legs carrying that diaper around?
It does look like full baby died.
Totally looks like.
See that's what an ass,
a big juicy real as it's supposed
to look like. It's not preposterous.
It's just outstanding.
Didn't know she had a butt implant.
She's got something to go on more
than one I would say that's it.
There's a photo there that has
the the two of them side by side.
They just curse her it
over it right there.
That's Jennifer Lopez and Kim Kardashians.
The one with the white right here,
here, here, here.
See the one on the left is Jennifer Lopez.
That's a real ass.
One of the right is Kim Kardashian,
is it? Yeah, when my ass obsessed and
spent some time doing other shoes down
the wormhole and it was a very bizarre
thing.
It is.
The attraction to shapes is very
bizarre to like like fake tits.
Like we know they're fake.
That always astounds me like it's not
that they look like bigger breasts,
they look like big.
Fakers did different things.
Some guys, some goats. Yeah.
I mean some guys meaning
it's a ton of guys,
but some guys make that distinction
like definitely not into that.
I mean you've said this before is that
you'd prefer hungry tits over big fakers,
hungry,
hungry little ones need to be fed.
I would rather give spoonfuls of
pasta to those hungry tits then. Yeah,
I don't like big fakers man. There's
something weird about them for sure.
It's not a trick. I will say a really
good job of fakes like you can.
There are some magicians out there that
create amazing, like they still look.
You still go like, oh yeah, those look
good, but I still prefer real ones.
I don't know.
I just liked it more.
There's also body dysmorphia thing
because when do you, where does that look?
Once you have a baby to your
tits, get mushy. That's it.
That's just, it's nature.
So what should I do? Should I get hoist
him up? Should I have them reduce?
Talk about it.
First of all,
he does shit to yourself with no one would
have kids and our population is going
to die off.
It's true quiet Jesus,
but it's fine to let you know.
You got to surrender. It's also
part of life, man. Yeah, for sure.
The trade off for making life,
it's now,
are these real or are these Lakers
nutrition and thighs into fitness?
I'm a clean and healthy for date.
There's surprisingly a lot of
nutritional benefits from me to seaman.
Some of it can get to read out to you now.
She eats a lot of calm,
teaspoon contains over 200 proteins,
several helpful bits,
mints,
calcium chloride,
citric acid.
See Sodium and think,
wow,
that's a not in the shot.
Kids on Youtube talking about it. You can
come. Yeah, we should all eat come. Well,
what I like about this,
because we've had other come eating clips
on the show is the science that this
woman is put towards it, that she's a
fitness expert, which is kind of neat.
We don't often have experts.
What does that mean though?
Fitness expert. And you can just
say you are being a little bit yeah.
And a life coach.
Anybody can say that there's
on certification sports
bra and then you're like,
I'm a fucking fitness thing is a weird
one. Anyone can sign up for that shit.
I was watching a Anthony
Robbins Instagram stories.
Tony Robbins is in, he's in Australia
and he gets out to that, uh,
was, was um, black Ip song.
Tonight's going to be a good
night and he's out there,
you're assuming is clapping with
his big fucking Frankenstein hands
and he's like, stop it around on
stage. But it's all like, it's,
it's like he's,
his energy is kind of forest and he's got,
he's a little too wide around the waist,
which means eating a little too good.
Living it up a little too much. It's
all just, we're all excited. Okay,
we're going to prosper
here, Huh? I mean crazy.
And it says one of the photos I saved
the photo because I was laughing so hard.
Uh,
I saved it
for me cause it said savage is a picture
of him and he's dancing around clapping
and it just says savage. I'm like,
settle the fuck down buddy here.
Where is it? He uh, by the
way, that life coach thing, but
savage, that's what his Instagram
story. Why is that savage? I,
it's it with his hands in his pocket,
but this is all his dad bod.
I like Tony Robbins a lot,
but the fake energy thing, I,
if I went to his seminar and he made me
fucking stand up and do jumping jacks
every five minutes, I blow my brains
out that stuff. He's like, yeah,
he's a fucking,
it's a giant,
giant is him or whatever.
He actually has a pituitary,
even the jaw,
you know the facial features.
He has like a very mild form of it and I
think so of the giant hog probably part
of what his confidence, his or her. Sure.
Every time and every time he's probably
meeting with his team and there's enough
push back on something. He goes,
let me show you some stuff.
That role in carpet and was like,
look at that thing.
Slaps that thank Donald Interns. Like
he's got a point and hold up pizza dough.
Yeah.
It looks like one of those.
So Cinnabons you buy at the grocery store.
Those are good. Good, good.
Look how thin you are, pastor.
I've been working at
Berwyn right back
by the way. Um, so that,
that whole experience
shaking come full.
She demands,
I know it's a friend,
it's a friend. He's like,
I'm not in a relationship with friend
did this for me. Nice guy. Well listen,
I would say honey,
I'll come in the,
but honestly the best way is to
just suck it out that we get it all.
I mean just for your sake
guys wash.
Yeah. I know this is important. I'm not
into watching people eat comment. No,
it's weird because outside of porn it's
disgusting. I think in porn, by the way,
when it's like eight dudes in the
glass is fucking gnarly favorite.
I have those boot like this,
have them all bookmarked.
It's not enough guys guys.
Oh, the real savages in porn who are these
like Ah. And they like, they keep it in,
then it's like no big deal.
But you can also see in the faith or you
can read someone's when they're like,
why didn't you see that? Yeah. And they're
like, if, if, if the flincher yeah,
that's the fake enthusiasm.
Well, yeah, I mean normally, but you gotta
think the ones that are really into it,
like, no they're not. I mean, you've
gotta be so fucking damaged to be like,
I love eight of eight
guys. 10 guys, chase.
Oh Mommy can give you an idea.
She's getting close to the camera.
It, it smells quite mellow.
Smells like bleach kills the,
I
don't even more benefits to drinking
semen for women because it's a depressant
because it contains Melatonin.
Oh, I can just take,
get that for vitamins. All right.
Ooh, I just got the chills for real,
but oh Jesus.
Dripping and nasty salty.
Surprisingly so.
It's not surprising. Let's see the,
if everybody is a guy who, who's the,
about what they're writing. I produced
some of my aunts, semen videos. Watch.
Give me a call. If you ever need
some straight from the source to tap.
I hope you at least give the donor
a hand job. You Selfish Twat.
I have lots of,
see what I can unload on
those big breasts. Jesus.
Why not disable the comments?
She so rocking.
Would you date her knowing she's drunk?
She's drank so many cum shots.
Yeah, of course. Yeah. I'm curious,
are you still have a whole bit
about that? Yeah. Know about, uh,
I dated a girl once and she told me
that when guys drink a fruit juice,
especially pineapple juice. Oh yeah.
It makes you calm. Tastes better.
And I was like, how many dicks do you have
to suck for you figure that out. Yeah.
No. What's not wanting to
asparagus? Not Good. Okay,
let's try roast beef.
The idea that you,
you've figured that out
through trial and error,
like there's something really
delicious about your coming today.
What's different?
What did you have?
Let's go over my diet to do
an autopsy of it too. Oh,
I drank some water and pineapple at lunch.
I get some water from Hungary.
That helped. Did you? One
thing I don't think you,
you got to see throughout there was a
four month build up basically to the weigh
ins. The Barista who is
fat Wayne's where we were.
Bert Kreischer Knight came on you.
I did see a little bit of it on Instagram
and on Twitter with the Hashtag bird
is fat saw. Awesome. Did you see how,
I mean like we had,
I want to show you this.
This is like people would call in or
like send in videos saying Burdis fat in
different languages. Oh
my God, this is amazing.
Why is twice the so far
Harbert Rawer Cordova, Luxor,
good birth Chrysler is Bert Kreischer.
You are a fat cards you off that Nick,
they and Tom Secura might
and then this was my favorite
thing. This was amazing.
People
that listened to the podcasts that teach
English as a second language would use
the whole fat battle to teach English
abroad and in different countries.
The Pan
India
slur you,
you want to
go,
oh my God,
Oh my God,
is this freak you guys out when you see
how popular this is. I love it when, when,
I mean there was,
I remember the first time we figured
out that anyone was listening,
it was back when we were with red bands,
so this is like 2010 or 11 2011 and we
were doing shows and we put out a thing
like hey tweet this.
And the first time that we saw like the
next day that it was pages of people
tweeted that I was like,
oh there's actually people.
I thought there was like a hundred people
listening to this thing. Yeah. I mean,
I didn't have any idea of it,
but when they got to this thing and
they're coming in from different parts of
the world and then we did a thing of,
hey mommy,
thanks genes where we'll go through
where you just say that to like the,
the teller. And then we started getting
submissions from all over the world.
Follow police people in the squad car,
the squad car pulling people over.
It was, oh, we had a cop to it. Um,
he ordered his whole like on,
on the job,
you use all the inside language to order
it and he's in uniform and like it's
just bananas, man. Yeah. It's weird.
I'm like, you know what I like is the,
the silliness of it.
Like the fact that all over the world,
something that's stupid. It's
a shared joke. Yeah. You know,
like that's what I like stupid.
It's fat. Yeah. Like
hundreds of these men, like hundreds of
them. Yeah. That's really nice. Yeah.
It's strange, right? This whole
podcast thing is very odd. Yeah.
Your podcast by the way.
Like I remember doing,
I'm on like I think episode three
or five of your podcast. Wow.
Like somebody sent me a thing.
Once they have,
they have like it documented all the
episode numbers and they're like,
you're on like the one of the first five
or seven and I remember it was on your
couch in your office at home. Yeah. And
you kept telling me to sit forward. Yeah.
The couches weird couch. Seems like it's
a good idea but it's a terrible idea.
But I wanted to ask you who gate,
like I remember you said that you liked
the opiate Anthony model of like just
talking. Yeah. But how did you, did anyone
else have one where you're like, oh,
people will listen to this? Like did you
like were you thinking of someone else's
podcast? Like how did you know
anybody would listen to one?
I think Adam Carolla had a podcast
he had at that time. I think he did,
but when he had it,
it was like a radio show.
He did his like a radio show still
does. Right? Yeah. Well that's,
that's actually is downfall now I
think. Really? Yeah. I think people get,
they don't want to hear commercials
that are 15 minutes. Right.
It's not necessary, you
know? And uh, I think, um,
I just like Dell opie and Anthony had
just people come in with no structure,
bunch of comics and just
hang out and start talking.
Did you ever imagine like that your
podcast would be like where it's at now?
It was crazy, man. It is really crazy.
There's no way I could have imagined it.
I wouldn't have believed it. It's
so nuts. No, it's just, yeah,
I just just thought it was fun to do.
I mean,
and like people mentioned it to me all
that like when I, when I'm in an airport,
they'll, you know, they'll mention they're
like, it just still happens though.
Even mentioned the weight load,
but like I saw the way last podcast last
week and got one episode got more than
6 million and the other one
was like close to 7 million.
That's nuts. Downloads. That
is not, that's then the,
and then there's youtube views on top
of it. Yeah. Millions on youtube. Yeah,
it was amazing. How did you know, I
mean, I think I remember we heard, oh,
Joe's doing a podcast. Well, what is that
like even hear about something? Well,
I started doing it on Justin
TV, which was like this, uh,
online webcasting thing
way back in the day.
And what we'd do is we'd do it live
from the green room and Joey Diaz would
always get mad,
shut that fucking thing off.
We'd have a laptop and we'd
be streaming from a laptop,
like from the little Webcam.
So we'd have a little what it was back
before laptops had webcams built in.
So we put a little webcam on top of it.
We talk and people would like,
and you were doing that before
all this? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
That was a long time ago. And then, um,
that was probably like 2003 or
something. Whoa. That's really long ago.
Yeah. And then, um, when I got back from
Colorado, it was kind of bummed out. And,
um,
uh,
I had to move back to California because
my wife was pregnant and you know,
we couldn't live at altitude cause
we were like it in the mountain.
I went to that house,
I was so happy up there.
I remember that I went to there to that
house when you were checking it out.
Yeah, we were doing, we were
doing comedy works. That's right.
And we drove up there and um,
and it was like up this crazy
road and you know, like,
like a narrow mountain road. And at the
very top it was like, it was beautiful.
Well for me it was a perfect combination.
Uh,
like it was the perfect balance for like
these shows where all these people and
the UFC, all these people then up there
just nature and quiet. I was like, oh,
this is what I need.
I need to balance myself out.
Like just to have enough calm so that
all this craziness sort of makes more
sense. Yeah. Yeah. Now. Um, so the show,
the podcast, obviously it's gotten bigger
and bigger. We've been talking about,
cause we all know people that like you
were a well known guy when I met you for
sure,
but you've gotten considerably more
famous but you're not a crazy lunatic.
Yeah. How does that work? How does that
work? You think? I don't know what I mean.
Like we, we, we all know people
that like can't handle fame well.
Well I do a lot of really
difficult shit outside of comedy.
I think that's part of it. Do you
think so? Yeah. I think part of it is,
first of all,
I have zero obsession with fame.
Like if all my fame went away tomorrow,
yeah, I'd be totally fine with it. Um,
as long as I have health and as
long as I could pursue my interests,
I'm 100% fine with it. Yeah. I'm
not really interested in fame.
I'm interested in doing
a good job. Yeah. Like,
I know that when people come to see me
that I have a massive responsibility and
I work hard on my stand up and I work
hard on my writing and if I have a bad set
it will fuck me up for months and it'll
make me like batten down the hatches and
grind harder. Like I don't take
it lightly at all. Right, right.
So that's part of it too.
But it's also,
I do a lot of different stuff.
Like I do yoga,
I do Jujitsu, I do archery,
I do a lot of working out.
I said I've been running recently,
I do difficult shit.
And in doing difficult
show you get humbled.
Like you're always getting
your ass kicked. Yeah,
I run them the mountains near my
house. Yeah. It's so fucking hard man.
Like every time I do like,
I know like that there's people
that can do it way better.
I know there's people that in way
better shape and I know that I,
every time I do it I get a little bit
better and so I just keep pushing on it.
Yeah. So I just concentrate.
Excuse me. I just concentrate on,
on doing difficult things. Do you
think though that, sorry, go ahead.
You say that that's probably way or
way healthy thing of doing so basically
you're saying that I'm not focused on
my ego and making me a bigger star,
more famous, more famous. That's
usually what people do, right?
Like I got to grow this thing.
You're focused is external,
which I think is better as a human being.
Yeah, I think it's definitely better as
a human being. I think the, I don't want,
I have zero focus on being more famous.
Zero, right. I pass on everything.
Like as far as like doing talk shows are
doing magazine articles or interviews,
I pass on everything to Shit I
don't do so do you think maybe the,
that these people who
don't handle it well,
it's that their whole focus
becomes just that they're like,
may we hear about them too much?
Like Amy Schumer is a perfect example.
You hear about her weight too much.
Like there was this big Google story.
I pulled up my Google, this is a story
about her breaking up with her boyfriend.
There was a story angle that
she broke up with her boyfriend.
Like why the fuck is that a store?
Right?
Cause everything's a story because
she's probably got a publicist.
The publicist wants to make sure you
get your name out there all the time.
Guess what? People get fucking sick of
hearing you. Oh yeah. So if people want,
and I'm sure if people are
sick of hearing me too,
but if you don't want to hear me, yeah,
it's easy. Yeah. It's easy to not hear me.
Like you got to go looking
for me to hear me. I shake.
The more you put yourself
out there, especially today
with, you know, it's, this is,
we're not talking about the
1990s like with social media,
it's so easy to get the word out for
all the different things you want to do,
that there's no need to
do all that other stuff.
And if you start doing all
that other stuff, I mean,
you can gain a few new fans,
but you also get annoying.
Yeah. You know, we all know,
we all know people that are just
overexposed. You know who taught me that?
Daniel Tosh. I was about to bring him
up. I was about to bring the best. Yeah,
and he, he has that thing. He
doesn't do talk shows. He's the best.
We talked about it at the Improv and he
made total sense with me and it really,
really like cranked home. You
know it. You're like, wow.
Yeah. He's like, yeah, I do.
I don't do anything. He goes, oh, sorry,
go ahead. No, just like he was just like,
I'm already famous enough, right?
Yeah. And he goes, he goes,
I'm doing an hour a week on a television
show where like they get to see me on
TV,
so I don't need to do more than that.
Like there's millions of viewers
watching this thing. The thinking bank,
those who like me are
already engaged with me.
Why am I annoying the rest of the
world if you're not into it? Well,
my podcast built up 100% from
someone telling other people. Right.
100% I didn't do anything to promote it.
I've never done anything I've
never done. That's banana. Yeah.
I had one big bump when rolling stone
did a story on me and that was one of the
most uncomfortable weeks.
That guy following me around and hanging
out when it's staring at me and writing
things down like oh yeah, it's like weird.
But that did give a a bump though. Yeah,
that was a bump for sure
that that gave me a bump.
But all the other bumps or just it just,
it was a gradual,
slow sort of escalation until
about maybe two years ago.
And then it just started really
ramping up like ridiculous. Like yeah,
many millions more per month,
every month, millions more.
And then just started getting scary.
We always referred to like when a,
I'll talk to other people about
it too about your model of, um,
cause I feel like it's definitely one
of your ideas just to hit them with
content. In other words, just
put stuff out there all the time.
Cause that's like every week. I mean, I'll
just be on Instagram and I'll see you.
You're like this,
you had a physicist on and you have a
comedian on and then you have a fucking
hunter on and you're just like,
well,
I'm just putting stuff out there and
then whatever you want consuming.
But it's also honestly,
it's selfish because these are all just
people that I want to talk to. Yeah.
So like if I at Lawrence Krauss in the
studio who's a theoretical physicist,
I have questions I want to ask him about
the, you know, the birth of the universe,
what he thinks the,
the boundaries of,
of infinity are and all these
different and fascinating people.
So I have these one on one conversations
with no interruptions for three hours
with someone who you would never get a
chance to do that in real life because if
you were at a dinner table with them,
they would get up to go to the bathroom.
They checked their phone,
other than people would chime in and
someone else would come over this as your
own conversation, just you and them alone
in a room just staring at each other.
And you get, you get an
education through that. I've got,
I've become a much better
conversationalist. I think
I understand people better.
I get, I understand motives better.
I understand interaction better.
I understand ego and understand all
kinds of weird stuff you pick up.
It's like chunking,
you know,
you just sort of recognize patterns
in people and you start applying them.
I just have a much better understanding
of myself and of people and a an end of
being a good conversationalist.
Yeah.
You've got your definitely
highly skilled at it now.
I mean not that you weren't before,
but I mean I think it's obvious like that
that's a skill you develop because you
work on it all the time. What's crazy?
Cause I never thought it was a skill.
I never,
before I started doing podcasts,
I would never thought being a
conversationalist is a skill. Yeah.
I would've thought, yeah, you
just talk to people. You know,
I notice it more like a, somebody that
does podcasts a lot. When I watched,
especially if I watch a television
interview, I can tell or I listen to them.
Like on the radio,
I can hear that,
oh this host is a give
or like a gracious host.
He's letting his subject, you
know, say what he has to say.
And then I can also feel like, oh,
the host is trying to dominate.
You pick up on it. You know,
like you're like, oh this,
he's making it about himself all the time.
That is an issue with people.
Like sometimes someone will interrupt a
really good story and take a side track
where they talk about themselves.
Like they have an opportunity
to talk about themselves,
but you're in a middle of a story. Oh
Brian, you've done this. Yeah. Yeah.
And it just becomes a real problem.
A lack of awareness and a clumsiness
can really sabotage and throw a monkey
wrench into the gears of a conversation.
Yeah.
And it makes it real awkward cause the
other person is aware of it and they're
trying to be gracious and get through it.
And then you know it just
when someone else is talking,
when two people are having a conversation
and someone else is just kind of like
clunky like it, it affects the
way you're able to communicate.
So like as a host of a podcast and you
having a conversation with someone,
part of the skill of it is like trying
to figure out how to get that person the
most comfortable and the most relaxed.
And then the most like I
asked the questions with the
enough economy of words to
get them to express themselves
the cleanest. Right.
That's why I don't like participating in
or listening to podcasts with too many
mics on them. They get rough, they
get robbed, it's too much and,
and,
and usually what happens is at least
for me as a listener of one of them,
I'll be like every interesting
point that I was looking forward.
Like I can hear coming gets
derailed and like taking them like,
well watching CNN sometimes and
there's like six people on there.
I just want to hear one, one person,
dude, I don't want to hear all this.
It makes me nuts too much.
Does like nine.
Sometimes it's too much and they're all,
they're all just like trying to get their
sound bites in there. It's so obvious.
I was watching something on
Trump the other day and it was,
it was just fucking gross.
What do you think of what the whole
current state of things with Trump,
it's what happens when you get a guy
who does not understand what being
president is and is used to running
businesses and then all of a sudden you,
you let them run the presidency and
he's trying to run it like a business.
He's firing people that he
doesn't agree with. Like the,
I didn't know that the president could
just fire the FBI chief like that.
I didn't know it either. But like when he
fired Comey and it's like the guys are,
he's a real pain in my ass and this
investigation, like what I get.
So obviously obstruction of justice.
I think he has like obviously
really wide ranging, uh,
liberties when it comes to hiring
and firing as press. Amazing.
And we didn't know about that
until this happened. Yeah.
Because most people have the good sense
not to do things like that because it
looks bad. Right? Look suspicious.
People forget though that
Clinton did the same thing.
Clinton fired the head of the FBI as
well and he fired him in the middle of an
investigation.
I forget what the investigation was.
I forget what the circumstances were,
but it wasn't as egregious.
But it was pretty similar
because this feels like, I mean,
at least from the outside,
it does feel like, you know,
every day it feels like this is heating
up into some like major scandal.
Who knows?
Cause evidence wise,
I know it's always pointed out that we
don't have any, you know, smoking gun yet,
but it does feel like it's cooking up
into something, you know? I don't know.
I think everybody wants it to,
that has that sense too.
Here's the question of like what's
inappropriate and what's illegal?
And I think a lot of it's
been inappropriate, but how
much of it is illegal? True.
Like Sam Harris is a podcast
where he had these, uh,
political experts on talking about what
Trump did when he had those Russians
over the White House.
And he gave them top secret classified
information about Isis wanting to use
laptops to blow planes up. And he's
like, Hey, you know, when you do that,
you've compromised all these people
that were embedded in isis that we're
telling the government about
this plan that they have now.
They have to get these people out and
hope these people don't get assassinated.
Like you can't, like in thinking in him
thinking that he's sharing information,
like, you know, I'll let you know secret,
like what you're doing is you're
exposing sources and it's, and you know,
it's obvious too that like,
he's the type of guy that loves having
that sheriff secret moment. Like,
I'm sure he was like,
you got to tell you something.
Well that's the whole thing
with Comi. Like, you know,
like he wanted to hug him and he want to
say, luck, I hope you can let this go.
But he's like telling someone to let
go a criminal investigation crazy into
being compromised by Russia.
And apparently they were
warned that that Flynn guy was,
he was compromised by Russia before he
even got into off a, they were, they were,
he was worn by the Obama administration.
And then when,
when Yates came over the, uh, the
deputy attorney general and warned, uh,
uh, Trump's lawyer about it, they still
didn't act for another week or two.
She was a gangster.
Those fucking hearings she was,
she was so good because she,
they were trying to chip away at her and
she was like, look what school? Yeah,
school. And I'm on the constitution
school and I'm on law school in Amman,
ethics and about her responsibility
to the American people. It's like, no,
I'm not going to institute a travel ban
on Muslims. You out of your fucking mind.
I can't do that.
This is a country of immigrants.
You wanted me to institute a travel
ban. So upsetting to me. Yeah.
It's know he's like,
he's like a murderer and you know,
and they all get caught
cause they brag about shit.
Like he couldn't help himself
talking about Isis. Probably
like, I got some good,
I got to share it.
I gotta Brag about the shit.
I love all the child's about how they go.
It's really difficult because of his
short attention span and he has a tendency
to be easily distracted.
He likes the visual aids to you.
If you talk about something,
you have to show pictures to him.
He wakes up in wines now with cable
news and he brags that I don't read.
He's like, I don't like reading. You
know? Another thing is hilarious.
Let's talk about the shows that he
watches. They're there, number one,
because everyone knows I'm watching.
Oh, right. By him saying that,
everyone knows that he's watching
these Fox News shows. I'm fine. It's,
it's hilarious that he believes
that that's why they're number one.
But we've never had a president light.
Like imagine if Obama did that.
If Obama said, well, the reason why this
shows number one is because I watch it.
Everyone knows that I'm amazing.
Yeah. Everyone, everyone loves Obama.
Oh, he loves Obama, so I love him. Yeah.
I keeps talking about Kanye. Kanye
loves Trump. He loves Trump. Yeah,
everyone loves Trump.
But the fact that he talks about himself
like he's fucking Roy Jones Jr Jones in
his prime and Roy Johnson's don't mean
he was the baddest motherfucker on the
planet and he was talking
about it in his prime.
It was a way to establish that he was,
I mean, it's a psychological thing.
He was like,
when Roy Jones Jr gets out to everybody,
joined Julie going to take care of
business and everybody's like, okay, yeah,
like a separate power
almost. Right. He was like,
I'm talking about this other
aspect of myself. Yeah.
He was talking about like this,
this superhuman force
that was Roy Jones Jr
Joe rocks the House Thompson box,
the motherfucking house.
Many presidents in the past where this
psychotic, but because of Twitter maybe,
but maybe it's because of things like
Twitter that we now see inside. I mean,
what if Nixon was this bat shit crazy too,
but because of the limited acts
Spo Nixon tapes, that's great,
but they play the actual tapes.
It's really great.
What he had a drunken moment with a,
it's a famous drunken moment with a
reporter where he was talking about how he
has the power to,
um,
just go into a room and make the
decision to kill 6 million people with a
nuclear bomb. And that, you
know, that that hangs over him.
Apparently he was intoxicated when
he was talking about this, this,
this nuclear option power.
That's another very terrifying
thing about the president.
The president really does have legitimate
power to, to wife out, to wipe out,
to use nukes.
I mean,
he has a lot more power than we thought
they did because there was so much
restraint showed by Clinton,
even by Bush. Believe it or not,
like bushes even criticized the
Trump administration, which is crazy.
And Bush, I mean, Bush seems like a
fucking, like a, like a liberal daisy,
right? Compared to them. So
reasonable Einstein compared to, well,
the Supreme Court, when the
Supreme Court ruled against, uh,
one of Trump's things and Trump's
like, I'll see you in court, you know,
whereas a dude that was
court. Yeah, that was great.
That was the best court man.
But like Bush,
they showed this clip of Bush losing
a similar ruling to this cream supreme
court and his reaction to it was
so reasonable. Yeah. He was like,
well we have to respect the court and
the court's decision and this is just the
way it is.
Although I'm disappointed.
I understand that they're doing
their best in like a big part of it.
I do think you're right though is is
the lack of Twitter restraint because
nobody would ever act like that.
I know they had sort lay,
there was an article that said they had
an intervention last week and they're
like, you're making it harder for
yourself and there. And they were like,
and they showed him with visual aids,
like when you tweeted this and then
this was the pushback and these were the
articles written afterwards.
Like you got to fucking stop.
It's hilarious. It is. I mean, who knows?
It's good in that we need to know that
this is a stupid fucking position that no
one should really have.
No one should really have the ability
to just be the top chimp over 300 plus
million people. It's crazy that you give
anybody that power. There's no reason to,
unless you raise a philosopher king,
even a philosopher king
is subject to the immune.
If he has an ego and
if he's a human being,
he has the same possibility of
going out of their fucking minds.
Just it's just too much.
But why risk it?
It's just there should be way
more checks and balances in place.
Nutty to even want to be president.
Of course,
it's an absurd job. They're
all, they're all megalomaniacs.
Who knows. Could be
next. Maybe a Glen Moon.
Hi, Glenn Moon officially announced my
candidacy armed forces commander and chief
office President United States of America.
If elected,
I will serve holy will of God named Jesus
Christ and Power Holy Spirit from God
and named Jesus Christ. Volt Moan
USA. President 2012 November.
Oh, he didn't make it,
Huh? I don't eat it,
but I don't know if he's
going to come back, man. Hey,
email person self described
18 year old former student,
Franklin or Churchill High School I met
earlier this year, 2011 library. Livonia.
If anyone knows Amy who my last,
I entering her friend's house on six
mile road service drive west of farm to
road after I drove her there and
my motor vehicle from library.
I would appreciate you giving
her my Facebook address.
You are l I could use some help
securing 18 to 20 year old vote.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well he was doing the sign of the
cross wise that helps presidents.
Here's some balloons out there.
What do you do with those?
Shoot them in the head or let them live.
I think you've got to
let them live until they,
until they show up at the address.
We have to keep them at containment
systems though. That's the problem.
Reagan let them loose and we need
to re get real them in a little.
It needs to be a park. Yeah. What did
Reagan do? He lowered the bar right?
The institutionalized,
uh, the mentally ill.
So we unleash them on the streets and it
crazy because he's the guy got shot by
a mentally a little breath
out now. Yeah, he's out now.
He has a, it's like some type
of supervisor but he's out.
But he was like supervise.
He has to go I think to his mother's
house or something and, but he's, yeah.
He's not in a prison. Yeah. So
weird. How old is he though?
He was probably in the 60s. He can
still kill. Yeah. Oh yeah, for sure.
Yeah. It's, it's, it's,
it's a bad job and it's not a,
it's not a smart job.
It was a job that made sense back when
we were dealing with kings and we said,
well, what's having an elected
representative instead of a King?
So it was a superior alternative.
And then we had all these
checks and balances like
representative government and
having senators and congressmen
and all these different people.
They were there to make decisions for
the individual states and the engine.
A little individual states could have
their own laws and regulations and it was,
it was a fairly good system for the time.
But when you deal with
electronic media and, uh,
our ability to gather information
instantaneously, like,
and communicate information,
like there's no reason why we shouldn't
be able to vote online. No, no, none.
We should all be able to vote online.
Registration should be super easy.
The very least the, you know all
these, I didn't know, but all these,
all these European countries do weekend
voting for national elections and it ups
their turnouts by like 60% yeah,
that's a great idea as well.
There's a lot of different ways
they don't want that though. Right?
They literally don't want any more
participation because first of all,
one of the things that you're seeing
with Trump that's really disturbing is
you're seeing the rise
of the asshole class.
Like there are a lot of assholes out
there that will never represented and they
don't necessarily agree with his politics,
but they have like an identity thing now.
It's,
it's more like they're in a a group of
likeminded people than it is even that,
it's like a political party. It's
like a cult. It's a douchebag.
It's legit. Like there's a lot of people
that are enjoying this because the,
they're on a team and it's like whether
they're rooting for the fucking dolphins
or they're rooting for Trump,
it's, it's kind of the same thing.
They identify with a clan.
This clan of people are a Trump
supporters, right wingers,
whatever they're doing,
but it's it.
They just happened to beat
Trump supporters and lingers.
They could be anything else.
It's just people love to be in a support
group of likeminded people that agree
to a certain thing.
I don't think that they also,
like I noticed during
the campaigns it was,
it seemed like it was a lot
more just fuck the other team,
like that kind of thing.
It wasn't like about like he makes
sense on these points. It was just like,
fuck you guys.
I'm going to just imagine if Hillary got
into office and was doing all the same
things that Trump has done as far as
like giving way classified information to
Russia,
compromising sources,
firing the head of the FBI because he
was investigating her. The lock her up,
lock her up,
lock her up.
All that was like a big chant during
the campaign member. Yeah. Yeah.
Well he's done shit way worse.
Why?
Worser and worser chick.
He's got worker from clip.
Oh No,
the Gypsies. Gypsies. Yeah.
Total white trash people and she's,
she's fighting with some other woman.
She was like, okay, shit. Just
got, why worser, you know?
No. What else is interesting? Um, the,
that I was listening to the Sam Harris'
podcast they were talking about,
I like the reviews are good.
Yeah, he's amazing. The real,
the real interesting issue is the ebb
and flow of support and that if the pro
Trump media unitedly turned on him,
because there was some speculation that
they were upset that Trump was doing
some things,
some intervention things in
foreign countries and mangle
it a meddling and other
affairs that they didn't want. They
wanted more of a separatist sort of like,
you know, it's going to take care of
itself and fuck all those other companies.
But when we started bombing Syria,
we dropped the Moab bomb and
all this different stuff.
There's a lot of people that
expressed some, like they,
some discontent. Like this is not
what we wanted it, we sign up. Right.
If it turns and they United as
a United front turn on Trump,
the very people that support them,
which by the way could absolutely happen.
Sure when you're,
when you're a guy who like
mobilizes those armies,
those armies of assholes,
they're stair subject to turn on you.
Especially if you're clearly
an asshole yourself. Sure.
If he does enough asshole ish things and
then one day they just decided to turn
on him.
They were talking about this like this
could be catastrophic for his campaign.
Look at it. Literally could the
very people that put him in office,
this same group, if they have
someone who represents them better,
well it's a Ron Paul or someone else,
someone who they can get
with philosophically,
but they don't think like
what for whatever reason
they just decided they don't
like him anymore.
Which can easily happen.
Totally.
Well it can happen to you because I
don't think Trump really believes all the
crap that he was saying
that he was behind.
Like do you really think he's antiabortion
like how many abortions has that
motherfucker probably paid for it himself.
You know what I mean?
Like he's not about all the stuff that,
do you really believe? I think he's,
I think, no, I know he's
a, he's a, he's a great,
you have to give them credit for being
the, the super talented self promoter,
super talented and organizing them,
filling things in the moment. Yeah.
I don't think he believes all that believe
and I know that he definitely lost at
least a segment of people
this past week with, uh,
having his first foreign
trip to Saudi Arabia.
Like there was a lot of people that were,
I mean I'm talking about like very,
very hardcore, you know, far right
people that were upset that like,
what are you doing going there and your
first foreign trip you should be having
them pay us back
for nine 11. You should, you know,
why are you basically mingling with
them negotiating an arms deal? I mean,
it's just,
there's,
there's going to be things that pop up
every week that people will, you know,
get upset about.
Have you seen the picture of Trump and
that Saudi Arabian guy and some other
dude holding on to that glowing
gas? So creative, what is
that going? What is that?
A global, yeah. And it's
like showing, it's funny too,
cause he was like the Anti
Globalist Campaign Guy, right?
It was like America first nationalism
and then now it's like this is a global,
but it's all about the whole world.
What is it with these people once
they get into office? Even Obama,
once he got into office, like became
kind of a different person I think.
Well especially like when you're
in that first term, you know,
I think everything just
shifts to like I got to make,
I got to get that second term. It's
all they care about. I mean that's it.
Or do you think that's a
big part of it because they,
they especially like the
one thing I will say,
I think I noticed with Trump is
I think at the end of the day,
I don't think he cares about
anything other than winning,
winning the campaign, winning
votes, winning for him.
He's a, I think he a highly,
highly, highly competitive guy. And to
him it's just like everything is about,
it's a victory. Whether it's
this executive order signed,
this is like a victory.
Uh, you know, the, the, the, when
the healthcare thing went down,
that was considered a loss.
I think that would probably suit
like destructive to his whole psyche.
And I think all he wants is to win again.
Have another shot at the presidency again.
Only because it means he won.
Not because he really cares
about being president.
I think he just wants to win
man. Yeah, it could be. Yeah.
I'm, I'm enjoying the campaign
at like the, the, sorry,
the coverage of Melania hating him.
Like there's there weighing stuff.
Like he tries to hold her hand and she
swats it away and shit like that. I enjoy.
Yeah, I think, you know, there's
a lot of stuff they read,
they reach obviously for anything,
right? Like if you're pressed,
that's the thing is like the
level of scrutiny on everything.
It's like they were holding hands and
then they let go and they're like,
she swatted that. They, you know,
they want to visit great animated gift
though where he looks over at her smiling
and then he turns away and she like,
yeah,
she's like incidents at the inauguration.
Yeah. That's amazing. It's weird.
It is weird. What do you think
that it reads so clearly too?
It's like you can say a lot of
these things are ah, your slip.
But that seems so much, cause
she's like, well that seems legit.
And also the fact that she doesn't live
there. Well fuck. What'd you want to,
she just, you know, that's not what
she signed up for it, you know.
And she did she sign up for, she signed
up for some Bj's and some scrolling. Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Some Fendi bags
teaspoon a day. And then how much dick can
you suck. Right. Let me think about it.
It's a great gig cause he's probably
only a horny a couple days a week. Yeah,
it's 75 or something like that. You
can only probably get it up a few days.
Even with Viagara probably only wants
to pussy a few days a week. Yeah.
And then the rest of the days a week
she's driving Rolls Royces party New York.
Yeah. Trump. So she's right here. Right.
And so he's gonna turn
back, smile. Big Smile,
right?
Yeah. It's a big smiler. But
you forget, she's my tribe.
This is actually the coldness of
the eastern blocker as well. Yeah.
My stepmother had a little of that
at a little, yeah, a lot. Yeah. Yeah.
So do you think that it's also like
part of the reason why she accepted this
position life in the first place?
It's like there's like, uh,
like a pragmatism, like a cold pragmatism.
Like this is a good move. Yeah,
of course. Yeah. Well she was a hot
check, right? She's like, I'm not sure.
So that's what you gotta
do. It's a, you know,
you can't model forever pictures of her
and it lesbian sort of photo shoot type
thing.
I know there's some nude modeling modeling
prison, Nudie pics of our first lady.
That's crazy. Yeah. That's crazy.
I be crazy. If they were like butthole
pics, if she would like to spread them.
Shot looked like a string
of spit. Yeah. Figures.
And we're back to your mom.
I got serious for a minute,
but we got back to the important stuff.
Clicks. Oh yeah. We're living in the,
one of the weirdest times ever in human
history is cause it's total uncharted
territory. Yeah. And was that
just glassing glassing dude that's
become in the hunting community. Yeah.
That's become a giant punchline. It is
all over. Like I sent you that meat eater.
Yeah.
They said we're going to beat you guys
to the punchline sending pictures out in
this glass and yeah,
it's a beautiful photo there.
Look overlooking this incredible landscape
and everybody just say just glass and
you know like when you know we have all
these like little inside jokes that one
went like so crazy haywire.
It went haywire.
People brought binoculars
to my shows in New York.
Look at the map. This is why,
this is why I came up here,
but slipping along, that's a
beautiful, I'll call him at all,
stopping along here.
Just glass and just go there.
But all of a sudden have my head.
And it also fired up.
And this also opened up
a whole new world for us,
which was the excitement of a dad boner.
Like when a dad gets really
excited about something,
that enthusiasm is not any other kind,
a different kind of enthusiastic. Yeah.
Well,
because it's usually for something that
nobody would get that excited about it
except for that. Well, you
know, he's a very famous,
both Fred Eichler people are emailing
us like, yeah, that's not good friend.
I did not tell you. I told
you to remember. He's, I
watched him on TV. Oh yeah,
you did say you watch his
show. Yeah. Yeah. And he's so,
he glasses whole like what's was
killed everything in the
world with a comp. I read it.
We read about him after it.
Yeah. He's killed the
animal kingdom. Yeah. Yes.
He's killed Noah's Ark with turbo w a
recurve bow is like a traditional old
Skool Bo. It's like legit.
This dude's just, Oh yeah.
He's one of the best bow hunters in
the world. Recognized. Hmm. Yeah.
So it does he know about this? I
don't know. I know we emailed them,
we reached out. I'm sure I reached
out this guy. He's probably upset.
People were all swearing. Yeah. Oh, he's
super nice. Oh, remember? Sure. Yeah,
he had that one.
He had a video where he goes and he
spanks a little cub bear that there was a
little bear eating out of like a dumpster
by his house and he ran up and spanked
it and was like, Ooh, ran back and
got all excited about it. Yeah.
He's like way out in the
wilderness. I don't know. I
believe he lives in Colorado.
I think that's it. Yeah, it's
glass. We have all these other,
so we started to look for dads that
get excited about things, you know,
like that. We consider him in that
category and like, so like there's,
you know what foamers are
no foamers are people,
they get really into trains and they like,
we'll wait at train stations for trains
to drive by and they fucking get really
excited.
Foamers Damn New York
once again on the SNC.
Yeah. So I'm trying, coming
here southbound on North Creek.
They get really into it then.
Boy.
Wow. That's cool. Well that sounds
quite,
Gosh.
Oh my God.
It sounds like an Alco,
oh 1943 I asked too.
Wow.
Oh God.
Oh Man.
Yeah. Okay. Cat Away. Wow.
Guys.
Just won't wait for trains like ours.
He's so excited about that train.
So excited.
Don't you kind of envy this guy's ability
to get super stoked on something so
dumb. No. That guy needs
to find pussy. Yeah.
You would just abandon all those numbers.
Keep rattling. It's our f four five, six,
two nine. Here's the solar
equipment. That's why their dads
look at this. Oh my God. It's
coming. The Moon's shadow is coming.
It is coming. The watch in front of, yeah.
Oh my God. Here it comes. Look at this.
I never seen him like this. No
flashes. Oh my God. Here we go.
Look at it. Oh my God. Whoa. Look at that.
Oh my God. Here we go. Oh my God. It's
coming right over a second. Sorry.
I'm looking at this. Oh my God. We're
getting close. It's getting close. No,
felt the dog. I got corona.
That is Diamond Bailey's beads.
Very big diamond ring.
Look. ADAC totality.
Oh my God. Look good. I mean,
it's cool to see. That makes
sense. Look at the phone.
Maybe that's it. Oh, look it down there.
That's pretty rare. Look
at it. Look at that.
Oh my God. But it does sound like
he's going to come with and, awesome.
I wonder if you took
that flight specifically.
Does that guy seems so into it
and was so much knowledge? Yeah,
it doesn't seem like a casual trip.
I think by far the craziest one
that we found because we've,
we've been sent a lot of these
things is this fucking guy.
I'm getting excited about something.
So God damn mundane.
The Trans Canada highway. Yeah. Oh God.
I love this one. I finally found the last
paved. Oh, okay, cool. Oh
Wow.
This guy doesn't Fuck
Trans Canada highway baby.
We are standing in
beautiful sunny Beretta.
It's Columbia.
The kilometer marker 7,128 and this
with a 90% no.
Make that 95% chance that this is in fact
the very place where the Trans Canada
paved. It's last woo.
I mean this is about a highway
being completed, right? Wow.
Canada has on asphalt belt and God Barco
and there was a highway.
Ooh. Goes running on it
and you're like, oh, those towels,
he's running on the highway right
in time down the middle. Oh,
oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, this is a downhill
sucks. Fortunately
so strong.
Yeah. I mean I like it. It makes
me happy every time. I mean,
why does it make you happy? Because I
lacked that enthusiasm for the road.
Like this guy has found a way to get
pumped on something so benign. See it. My,
my brain decided about, I
get excited about a lot of
shit, but this with this guy,
I see that and I go, okay, I want to,
to that guy about normal life there has
got to come up in a normal conversation
where he falls apart. Like
there's, it's a normal shit.
We talked to this guy about and he's
got some weird disconnecting, well,
I don't like to talk about bathrooms and
this is where he sublimating all that
weirdness. Yeah. He's finding he's
bottleneck in some way. He is.
And you're right about the lack of
sexual intercourse. There's no, wow,
this guy's good or any of these dads.
But that's why their dads,
because they show their dads that guy by
be a loner. Well, yeah, I think we're,
we're labeling dad. Yeah. You Call Him Him
Dad's cause they're older guys. Yes, yes.
I'm assuming that they're, they've shut
it down or their wives have shut it down.
The wife has a very short hair cut
and she's wearing Ku lots and sandals.
You know what I mean? Like
they're just shut down. Yeah.
Now Ladies and gentlemen,
your Trans Canada highway
as yours,
Canada,
it would be something that if you heard
back,
this video is dedicated.
All the men,
the women who made this great possible
at great highway possible thank you.
And you all caps exclamation points.
It's just, whoa, those noises though.
Or like
crazy crazy. That's gang bang. So yes.
I mean that's for a highway being,
I almost feel like he's seen every stretch
of it. Right? Like that's the thing.
Maybe this is the completion of 10
years of traveling is fucking highway in
documenting the whole thing. We like
to think of the backstory. Yeah.
Wasn't there for the construction.
Was He part of it somehow?
I had a guy on my podcast, Chris Cage,
who's a walk the Appalachian trail.
Do you know what the Appalachian
trail is? Yeah, it's a, yeah,
it's all through the
Carolinas, right? Yeah.
You start in Georgia and it goes all
the way to Maine and he walked in.
It took six months of walking. Whoa.
Yeah, and this was like a dream.
His dream. I don't know. He had it
in his head that he wanted to do it.
How did he eat? Did he bring, how
does the food work? Bring Food?
You buy food along the way.
Okay. Yeah. You bring some
food. Oh yes. My only concern.
Now you say you get you saying
that I don't get excited.
I have an email from a listener I thought
would be a nice time. Okay. Your Mommy.
Tina,
I completely understand your need for
Tom to have enthusiasm as my fiance is
just as chill an unexcitable as Tom.
There is nothing more agitating.
Them being excited for something and
only getting a smile from my man.
That just proves that you are the
personality champ personalities all about
getting excited,
having different moods and responding
accordingly to other people.
Clearly Tom doesn't have what it takes
to be considered a champ. It's all you.
Ps. I also get farted on and
treating less treated like a sister.
We are definitely into weird territory.
I feel like this only happens with
couples who are on the same playing field.
Lots of love, Hannah. Thank
youThanks. Huge mistake.
Do you have it now your email address?
I just want to say that predicting
to get more from Hannah now. Yeah,
10 is going to start crying for sure.
I caught him 40 on my sister.
Things are getting weird.
I can't believe you.
You think I don't get excited about
and I mean we discovered that Tom gets
excited about football but I mean,
okay. It was seldom is there a big,
I mean you've known him for years
too and gets excited when he goes to,
goes to shows when he does a
great show. I do. I get excited.
You Express your enthusiasm for good
shape. Fucking show. Yeah. Yeah.
You could tell he gets pumped.
Yeah, I do. I get a rush.
What is pounce look like from Tom Cow?
I like cars. I get excited
by cars, get excited. When I
saw, I saw one of his cars,
I got, I was used to seeing that was
what you had a video camera on me.
I was like, ah. I was glowing
at the thing. I like cars.
I buy car magazines and looking
at a kid. That's true. Yeah.
All the corvette. Right. So cool.
He's like a little kid. Yeah,
I do like it. So there you go.
You farted this morning. Uh,
horrendously this morning or last night.
Probably bug you excited about that too?
He changed.
I was a marital relations and
then afterwards we were, you know,
whatever, lame around and he
goes, you know, you're lucky.
I go, why? He goes, well,
I held in a Fart for you that
whole time. And I go, wow,
what a lucky gal and I should
get credit for that. I feel like,
I feel like some guys would have
let that go and I was like, nope,
don't do that right now. I
had just settled in, you know,
and I was like, Nah, don't let this
go right now. That's beautiful. Yeah.
See he can appreciate it.
It's amazing.
I get excited talking about this with you.
Be,
would she consider it
nice too that you owe?
Do you hold them in or do you try my
best and if I do accidentally let one go,
I'd let everybody know. Get out
of the way. Get out of the way.
Everybody clear house? No, you got ladies
around here. A little girls, right?
So yeah, house filled with girls. Thank
you gentlemen. I got the opposite.
It's all dicks all day
balls and farts.
Don't you think that you
get material out of that?
That's probably a blessing for
you. I'm used to it. I'm, you know,
I'm more male energy. Wait, not good with,
we haven't done this during the
show. You need to do this, Christina.
My big announcement just
means there's a big enough,
there's
a big news coming. Oh, it's a sound cue.
You know how like morning shows we'll
have like air horns or whatever.
We have chips in the ball.
She was in a bowl.
But what kind of chips of those things
are potato chips being poured into?
So loud? It sounds like, I thought it
was gambling chips. Yeah. Oh, right.
Oh, that's interesting. I've
never thought of that know know.
I don't think there's a distinction
made, but it's so clunky. It is. Yeah.
I think they're the thin lays kind.
That's the kind I see when I ruffles.
Yeah. Yup. Okay. Uh, anyways,
big news.
I'm finally shooting my hour special.
Oh,
you shooting it? All right. Here it is.
Denounce Mike and finally make it June 20
fourth@theshoeboxtheaterinseattleandticketsareonthousandranch.com.
The link is up and is active, so you can
get those tickets now. Please Mommy's,
let's pack it out so I can have a
great taping. There's two shows,
a seven and nine 30 Bang Bang.
And the great city of meat rattle.
I can't wait to go there with so many
mommy's there. It's gonna be awesome.
And I'm still very happy for you.
Seattle's on the shortlist of places
I would live outside of La as, yeah.
Same as me. I like, they're very,
yeah, get through the winter.
I'd just go to Hawaii a couple of times
or something to get through that fucking
rainy bullshit yeah. To deal with.
But once you get through that,
I think like intellectually, I think
it's one of the best cities. Like people,
they're not as pretentious.
They're, but they're smart.
There's no show Biz influence,
which I think is one of the things
that fucks us up here. Yeah. Is the,
the desire for fame. Like he's, it's a,
this is a total absence of that up there.
You see way less fake. Yup. Fake
tits, fake lips, fake ass people.
What is that? They look like people.
It's a really cool city. I um,
I didn't realize,
you know,
sometimes you just see like one
thing and in a theater and so you,
you don't know if you've been there
before. I did the more and uh,
I didn't realize until afterwards when
I went to the lobby that I'd been there
with you cause the lobby.
Yeah. Stood out to me.
I didn't realize that when
you're before in Seattle.
I did it a couple of weeks ago and
as as we were in there, they're like,
you've been here before. I was
like, never been here before.
And then we got the lobby and I was like,
I have been here before because I remember
doing like a meet and greet with you.
With a, yeah. Have we done so many places?
Do I forget? Forget them all. Yeah.
They all get, they blend
in Seattle. I mean, yeah,
every time I've gone there I've had some
of the most fun shows that the average,
yeah. That's why I chose that
city. I mean, I, you know,
La is obviously my heart.
Yeah. What'd you say? The the
showbiz element, that is the problem.
It's the problem.
There's not just a showbiz element,
but the problem that you were talking
about what that Instagram kids and the
Kardashians,
they're not necessarily even showbiz.
They were like at the attention
industry. The attention industry. Yeah.
It's like there's so much fake bullshit
and so much like flossy nonsense.
Crazy. Yeah. I mean,
I feel like Seattle is basis Microsoft
and Amazon and there's a lot of tech
money there and a lot of
really smart people. Yeah.
And it's also super green and I feel
like being next to the ocean and Super
Green, like you've seen a
lot of green mountains. Yeah.
It's something about that.
It's just better for you. Yeah,
definitely. I think so too.
If your brain is a very like kind
of showy town know that we live in,
it's like a very like show off thing.
I think one of the funny things is like
the idea like that you think you have
money in this town like and people who
are trying to come across that way and
you go to a town like
Seattle where like no, those,
those 22 people are billionaires and
then they're not even trying to show you
that there weren't like a sweater
Bill Gates dresses like a fucking like
killing and yeah.
Yeah. It's, it's odd, right? What
are you doing all that money. He,
but he does a lot of humanitarian sons
of it. That's incredible what he's done.
And he got a lot of other super
wealthy people to donate their money.
A lot of them like they do that. The
pledge. Well, how about Warren Buffet?
He's given it all that and that's through
gates. He's done it through gates. Yeah.
He's an interesting cat.
Like he's literally,
when he dies he will die and
leave it all to charity. Yeah.
So that's and there and he's been
giving a lot, some of it, those guys,
they've been giving
billions as they're alive.
Even Warren Buffet also lives in
like the same house that he bought,
like 30 Maha Nebraska. It's
a super normal house. Yeah.
It drove the same car for like 20 years.
Like why have all that money then?
No one understands.
Aren't you fucking flossing?
He's balling his level. You
should definitely be balling
slightly. A little bit.
The same lady, I think he's
divorced. He got divorced. Yeah,
she got like 1.5 billion,
which to him was like,
once you stop lik nagging at me,
take a little 1 billion
billion. Dot. Yeah. Yeah.
He's, he's still doing pretty
well now. Jude Dork titties.
That's a great city too.
Yeah. Jude Dork titties. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. That's a place
that I would consider living.
I would consider living in New York
City in the winter months. Yeah.
It doesn't bother me that much.
I think it's all about,
one thing is like in La after a while,
even though compared to most of
the country lifestyle, you know,
cost of living is much higher. It's still
significantly different than New York.
And like I would only go there if I
could definitely live at least pretty
comfortably. You know what I mean? Like
I've taught a baller, baller all. Yeah.
You don't want to struggle in New York.
My wife wants,
she's talked about moving there.
This is like one place where she said she
would go like, if you want to go there,
I'll go there. Really? Yeah.
I think she just thinks it's like
a big glamour shopping trip though.
So she looks at it. Well
she, she's right to a point.
I mean like incredible shock.
The other colds rough,
but you know, you just dress
warm, which is not that difficult.
So you'd be doing like eight
spots a night. I know that
you yeah, maybe but not,
I don't like that many spots as
much as I like longer spots. Right.
I think longer spots like too long spa,
take two,
one half hour spots over eight 15.
Yeah,
because as far as like
developing material, I think
it's really important to,
to stretch out a little bit because
you're creating like you've composing
something, you're putting
something together, a peak
and a valley. And you know,
Diaz and I had a conversation
about that yesterday. He was like,
I got to go to more places where
I could work an hour. He goes,
cause sometimes I'm home for like
a month and I don't go on the road.
I don't do an hour set.
And then I got to go do an hour set and
I got a piece it all together and make
that make sense at a like short
spots. And it, and especially if you,
if you're touring a lot like I have been
and you're doing that long set every
night. Uh, I, I don't particularly
get a thrill out of a 15 minute spot.
It feels like, it feels like, I mean,
I understand it's a totally
different thing and it's,
it becomes like a different skill set,
but it doesn't even feel that rewarding
because like the benefit is like,
it doesn't feel like it lines up with
what I'm doing. Know that you just can't,
and cooking. Yeah, yeah.
You're just getting started in
the light goes on, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I know what you're
saying. But to me, I treat them as blocks.
Like I have a four 15 minute
blocks. And so like, uh,
like if I'm doing a set tonight, I'll say,
okay, well I did this block last night,
so tonight I'll do this blog. And
that's true. You know? And then, um,
one of the cool things about La is that
I can do three or four blocks and night.
Like I'll do one set at the Improv and
I'll do two sets of the comedy store.
I did three sets of the comedy store and
one side of the Improv on two Thursdays
ago. And you had like a
killer feature sets. Yeah.
Well no one one different
to the same and one was uh,
the um, uh, Jeremiah Watkins fuck
around shy. Yeah, yeah. I'm doing that.
Next thing that's a great show.
Can't wait. I've never done it.
Oh it's the best people.
They yell at a subject and then
you start riffing on the subject.
It's just yell out like
cats. Yeah, Yup, Yup.
And you start talking about it and it's,
you come up with material and punch lines.
You come up with taglines,
you come up with,
like you might have a,
a section of something that you've
ran about that doesn't fit anything.
And then one day you have a
new bit and then you go, oh,
and then there's that thing that I did
on stage that night and then it slides
right into there. I'm a big believer
in that. It's not that hard, you know,
relatively speaking to
say something like a joke,
come up with something funny.
It's much more of a challenge to come up
with an interesting topic or a premise,
you know? So that's what like that,
that show sounds exciting. Yeah.
I feel like I'm saying like
talk about this topic. Yeah,
premises are giant premises are
giant and a point of view is giant.
And then from there I feel like it's like
that's the scaffolding that you'll add
jokes too and you'll figure out a way
to make it funny and figure out a way to
just do it the right way.
And for me,
one of the things that I started doing
really recently that really made a big
difference is, um, I'll, I'll have
a bit, even if the bits killing, uh,
and I know like this pits
going well is developing well,
I will outside of stand up,
I'll sit in front of my computer and just
write on that subject right on it in a
completely different way. Like,
say if I approach from one,
like say like you're talking
about going on a boat,
you're approached it from this way,
then I'll just approach it
from a completely different
way and just say, okay,
well this is already in the can, this
one's done. All right, I've got it.
So let me just try a new attack on it.
And I've come up with so many different
punchlines coming at it from a different
angle, but forcing myself to sit in
front of the computer and you know,
I used that program, right.
Room ever showed you that
program, blacks, everything,
blacks, everything out and gives you
green font. So it's like the matrix font.
Yeah. And I just sit there and I can't
access email. I don't get notifications.
Nothing.
So when you, um, when you
write from a different angle,
will you then in your bit do the
chunk that works and then be like,
or what if somebody, and then like all
of a sudden present the other angle?
Sometimes it fits in, sometimes it just,
I just find a way where it fits in.
Yeah. But it just, it's just creating
more tags lines. Uh, more tag lines,
more punch lines. You have a new
hour though, right? Yeah. Yeah.
So how long did that take you? It didn't
take you that long. Six months. Yeah.
That's awesome. Every day I'm
hustling. But I've seen you actually,
it's a good lesson
I think for a lot of a lot
of comics. Like you, uh,
it came out and then you didn't, haven't
chilled at all on that. You just like,
we're were,
I've see you,
I see on posts all the time that you're
just like spot spot, like working,
working,
working all the time.
Yeah, I do. Um, five or six
nights a week. Lately. At least.
At least four. Always at least four.
Really. Like I worked last night.
I take off tonight, I work Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday.
I got a hot date with the wife and
then I'll probably work Sunday too.
And then I'll go out it again next
week. And you're doing, by the way,
congrats on this tour because I saw it's,
it's big time shit, man. It's crazy.
It's crazy. It's because you're doing the
theater at Madison Square Garden. Yeah,
it's almost sold out. That's what's great.
Is that like 7,000 seats or something?
That's some something crazy, crazy.
Dallas was nuts, man. Dallas was a,
I just did Dallas. It was the biggest
place ever sold out. That was 6,000 seats.
It was maniacal.
That's crazy energy that you get.
How do you like it?
Because it's a total different
thing from 1500 or 2000 seater.
It's different.
It's a different thing,
but the energy when you get
6,000 people laughing is crazy.
It's weird. It's just circuits. Oh roar.
So it's a, it's a different feeling,
but you know, man, I just, I
really like creating stuff. Yeah.
I really like putting
together, stand up, you know?
And I really love the process of writing
things down and going over my notes.
I'd love the process of
creating new material.
I love the process of sitting in front
of that laptop and staring at the screen.
I love the whole process.
I love the process of going on a run and
like recording a new idea that I have
in my head and then looking at the
notes that I have on my phone and then
breaking those down on paper and then
sitting in front of the laptop and then
taking these ideas,
smoking a joint,
going on stage with it and riffing with
it and then recording it and listening
to the recording on the home.
It's like the whole process to me is I've,
it's my favorite thing to do. It
really is. Other than you know, me too.
I think it is like the biggest thrill
I was talking to somebody about it that
like,
I think the biggest thrill still of all
things is coming up with something new
and having it be, you know, the
validated and rewarded. You're like,
that's a bigger thrill than
anything. Yeah. It really is.
Like I thought of this thing,
I said it and this group
of people reacting and then
abandoning it. Yeah. Yeah.
You have to have staff.
Do you do or record a special,
like somebody yelled out like do the Kim
Kardashians, the Bruce Jenner bit, right?
Yeah. And I'm like, dude, I don't
even know how to do it anymore.
I literally don't know how to do it.
People don't understand that.
Only comics understanding.
Yeah, there you go.
I've been doing this other thing for so
long now that I don't remember the beats
of that.
Somebody tried to get I,
I started to do one and I was like 30%
through it and I got an a on what happens
next? The audience yelled out the next
line. I was like, well there you go.
You guys know.
Then as I'm ramping up
to tape it in a month,
like I have to sit down and really go
through my notes and really remember every
little beat. Yeah. Bump to
it and bell and whistle.
Cause of course forget the cadence,
get away without doing that.
But make no mistake about it.
The more attention you spend thinking
about that material, the better.
Yeah, most definitely. Yeah. And
I have to get full focus. Like,
I can't fuck around with anything
like it's laser until that date.
You know what I know that's
really kind of weird.
I know guys that write on shows and
they'll write sitcoms scripts and they'll
write movie scripts and then they,
they have like a chalkboard
or a whiteboard and they're
right on the whiteboard
and they'll have notes that put
like scenes, different scenes,
but they don't ever do that
about their own act. Right.
And, and then their, their,
their own act, they treat like, you know,
like a red headed
stepchild and never really,
they never really have that kind of
professional focus cause you don't have to
because no one's telling you to write.
But when it comes to like writing
a show or writing a movie to,
you have to write that because
everyone's going over bit by bit.
You have writer's meetings, you go to the
writer's room, you sit down with people.
There's no writer's room or
writer's meetings for standup.
Well why isn't there like why? Why
don't we, because we're fucking lazy,
nice discipline.
It's self discipline.
And also it's hard to look at yourself
and look and step back and separate you
from your work and got, yeah, that
kind of sock like that can be better.
I should do this there.
You know what I love the most is knowing
that I'm about to say some crazy shit.
Like when you're like you take the
risk and in your heart you're like, oh,
I'm so scared of this could be really
there. Shouldn't, I shouldn't say this.
And then you say, yeah, you get addicted
to that feeling. Yeah, I like that part.
Like I'm going to take a leap right
here. Yeah. This is scary. And yeah,
hopefully they'll come with me.
And it's not just talking about airplanes
and cats and dogs. You're like, yeah,
they say some crazy shit.
Yeah. And they, and then
there's a, there is that the risk, the
risk is what the, is that feeling of like,
yeah, there's this pair shoes it,
yeah. And then the, the like, it's,
you don't think about it at the time,
but the knowing that a bunch of
people are getting babysitters,
they're spending their money,
they're coming out to see you and there's
this massive responsibility to incite
a reaction in them.
Yeah.
With just your words and thoughts and the
amount of responsibility that's on you
do that. It's pretty intense. I've, I've,
I've paid more attention to it over the
last year or so that I have like ever in
my life. Yeah. Have ramped
it up more. Yeah. I've, I've,
I just think it's constantly,
and then my standards always get
hired too. It's like I need to,
I can't have a new special that's not
as good as the last one. So I feel like,
man,
I gotta make sure this one's better.
So I have to like watch my old one and
go, well, what were, where's there?
Too much fluff. Too much. Oh, you
did that. Really? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like maybe I could cut this down.
Maybe I shouldn't.
Maybe this isn't as good as
this part. You know, all that.
It's just all sharpening the Samurai
Sword, hammering that fucking metal down.
Yeah. I know. My problem is
I'm a perfectionist, so like
an, it's never good enough.
It's never going to be, that's
everybody's problem. I hate it.
Everybody hates if anybody who's any
good hates everything they do. It's true.
Everybody I know that loves
their act is terrible.
Everybody tells me all my new stuff's
amazing. I love it. Get away from it.
It's gross.
I've heard the,
remember we did this job one time where
that guy was like, oh, it goes like,
don't show that of going
back and watching. Yeah.
I love watching yourself and like it was
terrible. It was terrible. There you go.
That's always the case. Yeah. It's weird.
It's always the case and there they're
always like big self promoters to, Oh God.
Yeah. Yeah. Letterman hated himself.
I read some book about him years ago and
every episode he would go home and just
put on the hair shirt and
flog himself like that.
I was the worst episode ever and
I, in my estimation, he's the best.
I love farming so much. But he why
he's the best though. Yeah. Cause he,
cause he had these high standards,
he wasn't just half ass it. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. It's true.
I remember a guy one time asked
me to get them a guest spot in.
It's like I went to a city and he was
like, I knew him, I met him before.
So I talked to the manager
of the club and I was like,
can I get this guy a guest spot? And
she was like, are you vouching for him?
I was like, yeah, yeah. So cause okay,
so he goes up there,
just eats such a big bag of shit.
So then the club manager is like, what
the fuck was that? And I go, wow, I just,
I dunno. So there's a second
show. And I go, dude, that
was like, yeah. He was like,
I know, I know. He's like, I'll do a
totally different set on the second.
So totally have different set and, and
I'll, I'll make up for it. And I go, okay.
So I go, let's just let him,
he'll do a totally different set.
No,
not only does he do the same set,
he does x verbatim the same opening and
since she's looking at me like what's
going on? And I'm like, I see him. I
go, yeah, you did the same exact thing.
And he was like,
yeah,
what was his reasoning blackout
or something. You got nervous.
And the other thing is that
that stood is that he had, this
is quite a few years ago,
like amazing website and like all this
other stuff had incredible attention.
You know like those guys. Yeah. Yeah.
When you started doing standup
and the car, I bought new cards.
I remember that like cards that
say your name and like, like about,
this is every time I meet a guy in a
town and he wants to do a guest set,
I'm almost positive they suck.
They're always like real true to him.
And I really love to
have guests on your show.
Would guest said there's 6,000 people.
So you're going to do a guest bet.
I know a bunch of guys do that.
I've had.
I've also had guys that are like
marginal headliners and you know,
work in comics.
Just show up,
just show up at my show and asked to do
a guest set. I'd like to Chicago Theater.
It's crazy. I'm not kidding. 3,700 people.
Hey, I like to do a guest set. Hey,
I'd like you to go fuck yourself. Yeah,
tell them what do you say? No, I go to,
this is all set up like this guy's
going to do 20 a you know he's got,
Ian's going to do 20 Tony Hinchcliffe
so coming into 20 and then I'm doing an
hour and 10 like this is what
it is. Is it? This is the show,
like there's no room for your guests
said, I'll just do like seven minutes. No,
you're not doing anything. I don't
even know what you're doing. Yeah.
I don't know what kind of moody,
what if you go up on stage and
you start doing my, my subjects,
like get the fuck out of you
just got an email about theater.
It's about one for a theater show where
they were like, but here's the thing.
Would you ever do that?
Never. Never the thing.
Imagine showing up at a, if you were
a musician, there's a band plan like,
hey man, I just like to go home and do
a song. Which is like what the fuck?
Fucking mind.
Well the crazy thing about this email too,
cause I've had this a few times,
is it's an email saying, hey, you're
coming to the city. I'd love to do a set.
Not only do you not know who I am,
I will provide no link to anything
so that you could check out.
Like in other words, it's just sight
unseen. You don't know anything about me.
Can I be on your show?
Can I do like 20 minutes?
That's good to know. You
know, maybe like five.
I had a guy show up in Atlanta
and he wanted to do a half hour.
That's what he said. Yeah. I said,
do you want to do, he goes, he goes,
I want to do a guest set. He goes, jump
note. Only talking like 30 minutes,
not like an hour.
I remember once I had hockey.
I love Dan Godfrey.
He used to run the Brayer Improv and
now he like overseas I think all the
Improv's. Yeah. And one time I was
in a brayer and I was, I think man,
I want to say I was
middling. This is like, uh,
probably like oh six or something.
And the, but I was, oh I was,
yeah it was middling. And the, the MC was
like, I'll do turn to him. I was like,
I'll do 20 and uh,
and then him and then Dan goes,
you'll do 10 you won't do a
minute more like just straight up.
Cause the guy was like announcing how
much time he's going to do from the AAMC
slot out. Yeah. He was like,
I'll do 20 and then how much
do you do? And he's like,
do 10 and not
a second more
telling him like don't even
fucking dream about doing that.
Yeah. And people get mad
listening this inevitably,
oh I'll get an angry tweet or an angry
Facebook message and people will get mad
thinking that,
you know,
like you just don't appreciate
people that are trying to make it.
And when you were trying to make it,
listen,
I'm telling you all the people that
are out there listening that have that
mindset, no one does that. No
one who's any good does that.
It's just not what you do.
You don't ever ask for guest spots.
If you get to know someone and you start
working with someone and you work with
them on a regular basis and you want
to work with them somewhere, you know,
that's one thing.
Like say if you know,
like say if you were going to be in town
doing a wedding or something like that,
like you were a friend who was getting
married. So my dad, he like, dude,
you're working that night.
And I'd be like, yeah, you
want to do a set and be like,
fuck yeah. And then we would work
around it. Sure. I figure it out.
But it's only because we've
worked together so many
times and know each other so
well. Like to have someone who you
don't even know want to interject.
Like your s your show is
like a complete package.
Like you've put it together, right?
You know who you opening acts are,
you know what kind of material they do
totally and you're thinking about how
this whole thing is going to play out
together and you want to make sure that
that audience who gets that babysitter
and goes out and we do want to make sure
that they get the best set possible.
And I'm old school I guess in the
sense that I am 100% of the idea that
everything at any show is
absolutely all about the headliners,
desires and wants for it's their show.
Like whenever I opened for you and like
somebody would say like, Hey, do you,
I'd be like, I don't know, ask him. It's
his fucking show. Like we're all here.
It's called support for a reason.
Like we're supporting the headlining
act and I fucking hate when they try to
involve anybody else in decision
making or how do you want to go.
It's all about whoever's name is on the
more whatever they dictate is the way
that show goes and you
should respect that.
You should respect what it took
for them to get to that point.
And you should respect their
desires at the show though,
if you want to talk about lighting
or music or how much time all,
it's all that person's
decision so everybody else
can go fuck themselves. Yeah.
You know what? I also find to be a
problem that I don't, I don't do.
I don't take guys in the road to do
crowd work. Oh boy. Get your life.
It just opens up Pandora's box.
It becomes a real problem where when
someone loves to do crowd work and they
start what you do for a living, sir,
I'm looking at you with that suit on.
I'm imagining good salesman and
now you know that the problem
people start boozing and they want to,
I'm going to get my chance.
He's going to talk to me,
and then they start gearing up and then
it at the time never comes and then
you're on stage and they
want to start yelling,
sit down. You're like, oh.
It changes the expectations of the show
and somebody who's the show is not about
them has made that decision.
That's what's fucked up about it.
I've had that were like,
Holy Shit.
One Guy did eight 20 minute Crowdwork
set front of me. Really? Yeah.
And did like a, I mean this is
few years ago we got it worked
into a frenzy and then you get up there
and if some guys like and you're like,
shut the fuck up. I'm not talking
to you man. It's a problem. Yeah,
it becomes a problem because
then the audience mad at you.
How come you just get to talk?
All right, why don't I talk.
Guy was waiting to talk.
Yeah, I just love it.
They used to really mismatch my opener.
It's like,
this is back in the day I was opening
Fort Lauderdale and they gave me this, uh,
this guy who was like,
ladies, you will guide us.
Suck Good Dick.
That's why they call it a blow job.
Not a career. Some shit. And I was like,
all like, ladies, you got to suck Dick.
Get the fuck Outta here. Like, do you
even know who I am? No. Don't give a shit.
They're not putting care. They're
not considering it as your show. Now,
that guy would never even be near me.
Like a guy that the club
found funny and they go, yeah,
I've got it open week for
male to female comic plus it.
Fort Lauderdale
is there other than Jim Brewer,
is there a funny comic that's ever
come out of Florida? Is he had,
is he had a Florida? I didn't
even know that crusher.
He's Tosh tosh before too. In
Florida too. There goes my theory.
Todd Barry's Todd Barry said Florida.
Wow.
But I know you're saying in terms of like
the fame, there's not abutment there.
They developed somewhere else. There's
one other guy too that's really fun to,
they came out of Florida. Um, Brian Regan
didn't, Brian Regan came out of Florida.
You might be right. Yes. He's from
Miami. Yes, that's right. Yeah. So my,
my theory sucks. Yeah.
But no, you're right.
But there's no bastion of comedic
glory like Fort Lauderdale's not worth.
We all go to get really good. Well,
there's no community, right? Yeah.
Apparently there was developing one in
Miami because last time was in Miami was
a couple of years ago and I did the uh,
you know,
they have that South
beach comedy festival.
I went with you on this right
and we were after the show,
we were talking to some people, it's one
of the local bars. They're like, yeah,
we're local comics. We have like
a comedy show here and a bar here.
And like we put together like a
real community. I'm like, Oh yeah,
like that didn't exist for a while.
Miami was the worst impression
history of people don't,
I'm walking around the world,
they cancel my week.
I got a call like a month
before and they're like, look,
we can't sell tickets for a white girl.
We're going to have to pull your week.
And I was like,
no problem.
A month before they knew were
like the writing's on the wall.
No one take it for this white
girl speak English. That's crazy.
Shows that Joey d is used to do half
Spanish shows there. Like he would,
he would yell out half the punchline
would be in Spanish and people would fall
out of their fucking chairs crying,
laughing.
We did shows there and they were just,
it was thunder dome. It was chaos.
It was chaos.
It was,
I did a set there where I would
weave in and out of Spanish too.
And that's right. You speak
full span. And I would,
and it would be crushing it pandemonium.
It would be nice.
And I did one one time middling
and the headliner did 35 minutes
afterwards. Oh my God. He's like,
I'm out of here. Almost have
to be bilingual. Yeah. Yeah.
And that like if you,
if you were to ask that staff like
are you going to police the room?
They'd be like that.
No Dude.
And everyone was 18 the audience was all
under each and they gave away tickets.
It was a whole papered room. They told
me a story about how, you know there was,
that was in coconut
grove and there's some,
there's some bad parts
near that in that area.
Like they would also tell you like,
don't walk down the street from
the club and you're like, oh great.
And so this one, you know
there's like this Haitian
gang, I forget the name of it,
but anyways, dominant in that area.
So one time, some guy, I don't know,
he's being loud or something. So they
go to one of the guys is like, Hey,
could you keep it down?
And then when he comes back a second time,
the guy opens his jacket and shows
him he's got a gun in his waistband.
So the guys like fucking, I'm not
getting killed over the Goddamn Improv,
you know, so he goes, tells the manager,
the manager knows that the head Honcho
of that gang is a big fan of show.
It goes to shows there.
So, and he's in the room.
So they go tell the gang leader that like,
hey,
this other guy just flashed
a gun to one of my staff.
And that guy just turns in the
middle of the show to the guy who,
who showed the gun and was like, Hey, no.
And so he got up, went out to his car,
put his gun in his car, came
back, was like, sorry about
that, and they were like,
all right,
there's no involving anyone else and
no throwing him out or just like be a,
be a decent guy. Put your gun
in your car. Christ. Yeah.
That room was chaos. No, I did it. I,
I've done the room
before it. Yes, go ahead.
It was one of the first clubs that
I said I would never go back to.
I told them on stage,
I go,
you are the dumbest fucking people I
have ever performed and they were howling
laughing. I go, you don't
understand. I'm so serious.
I'm like, I'm not coming back. Yeah.
I remember Diaz having some
choice words about it too.
He was when Diaz is like this too
fucking crazy. Still fucking crazy down.
There are a lot of nail was a
close second. I would say Miami.
It was number one in Fort Lauderdale
at the Hollywood improv. Yeah.
I always had a good time there.
The Seminole. Yeah. For me. I mean,
that's when I was like coming up,
whatever it was. Okay. Dot. A Bluetooth,
Bluetooth. Oh, those Bluetooth
taxis. I remember those guys
stopped. They ended, thank
God. Isn't that weird?
Do you know of Ryan sickler story
about that? So he had a, uh,
he needed a tape for something. And so
Ryan sickler is one of my good friends,
very funny comic set up.
And you know what it's like when
you taping a set for something,
you want everything to come together.
So he sets up a camera in the back of
the Hollywood improv and records his own
set and he's up there having a great
set killing leave stage like I got,
I got my set to submit to whatever thing
he's sending it in for comedy stars or
something.
So he's just happy he gets back to
review it and a guy sitting next to the
camera, the tripod with the camera as
soon as Ryan gets onstage was like, hello.
Huh? Comedy Club comedy.
I'm at a comedy club.
And throughout.
Ryan said,
you just hear the guy on his phone
calls saying over and over comedy club,
I'm at a comedy club.
So that's what Ryan has a tape,
guys yelling,
I'm at a con,
you know Bluetooth Man,
that Bluetooth Cleveland though.
It's interesting.
I don't want to see them anymore. It was
almost a point of, um, it was like a,
like a floss. It was like showing like
you were telling people that you had one.
It wasn't about I need to get
calls all the time. It was like,
you see the blinking, I'm a businessman.
I'm balling Cleveland Improv.
It was just like a sea of Bluetooth
ear pieces. Man. I gotta get back.
By the way. That one was rough, terrible.
Cleveland seems to have made a comeback
though. Cleveland is doing. And I, and I,
you know, I've had great
shows in that city that I, I,
but that club,
Cleveland Improv,
I definitely had some fucking
really bad crazy shows.
I mean,
there was a guy arrested during the show
who he sent back because it says one
pound chicken wings and he goes, that
wasn't a pound. And they were like,
it's what it is man. He was like, take
me to the kitchen and weigh, weigh them.
Cause I know that's not a pound.
And they have a, by the way,
this is one of the clubs that there's
a permanent police officer stationed in
the lobby. And so they were like, no.
He's like, well I'm not paying for it.
So they just get the cop and
they go, hey, here's the deal.
And the cop goes, look, I
thinking like this is, look man,
you're either paying for them, I'm taking
you to jail. And the guy just goes,
there you go. Go ahead.
So they arrest him. Wow.
Over an order of chicken wings.
He didn't want to pay for it. Wow.
This is not a pound. That
was the Cleveland Improv
merge stolen off your tape.
I had merged,
stolen at the Cleveland Browns who still
your March people like they were like,
we want a picture.
And they like totally distracted me.
And then when I looked down I was like
doing my own thing. Then like, you know,
I have plenty of these,
there's like five gone.
They just set me up for a picture and
then I turned back and they were gone.
Like, know who the people were. Just see
them leave. Did you go after that? I mean,
I, it's like I turned and I was like,
Hey, I'm telling like this security guy,
like they just stole it. He was like,
yes. Sucks man. Like it wasn't like,
you know, it is man. People
Steal Shit. You're in Cleveland.
Yeah. Tried to sell cds. Yeah,
man.
Yeah. I was such a rough, the first night
I ever did the Cleveland Improv, uh,
uh, uh, John and a pimp. I have a chart,
you know what I'm saying? The pimp,
the hooker and the John,
we're getting in a fight right at the
front row and they got thrown out like
this is who took a hooker to a
show. Yes. I found out later,
I didn't know at the time and
I was just starting my set.
Here I am my first time in Cleveland, just
trying to survive and I look in there,
they're getting ushered out.
I'm like, what happened? Well,
it was a hooker and a the John,
they're in a fight and that it had done
anything on arrest and they have to,
yeah, I've had people vomit in my
showroom on Cinco de Mayo. Okay.
As a Cleveland and probably the ones
that was grinding through a rough set and
this guy and the third goal
goes, uh, he goes terrible man,
like fully loud.
Like this guy's terrible.
What's up man?
And then some lady in the bag goes,
your mama should have swallowed that nut.
Like God,
meaning like this is in
Cleveland? Yeah, the Cleveland
Improv. Wow. I was like, damn,
yeah, I go, your dad should have stuck
around to raise you. And then, oh,
and then like I got out of
there pretty quick. It was,
what did she say when you said
that? Uh, it, it was just, it was,
there was so much oohing and aahing and
like, and swearing, and then she was,
she was removed.
So like she was allowed to say her thing.
I said my thing and then there was like,
fuck, fuck, fuck. Like fuck you, fuck you,
fuck you. And then they actually throw
them out. What happened after that?
The show calm down or
no? Yeah, they let me,
it was like as I'm winding into the
closing bit of the set, so I was like,
it was right before I shut it down anyway.
Like it was,
I was about to close and then,
yeah,
I mean I remember I walked pretty fast
offstage though as I got out of there,
but that was, that was, there were
some rough sets in that room and yeah,
Cleveland's rough. But, but hilarity
is, is pretty fucking different.
That's different. Yeah.
Different. Yeah. It's like, it,
it's a beautiful room and like, you know,
I mean, they'd probably has great clubs.
Don't get me wrong. Yeah. That's like
a rough rule. How's it different?
Yeah, I was there recently
with Fitzsimmons polarities.
Yeah. I was there on a,
I can't, I flew in on Thursday night.
I had a show there on Friday and uh,
fits in misery on Thursday.
So I did a set on his show on Thursday
and it was great. This is great.
He's hilarious. We started out like a week
apart from each other. Did you really?
Yeah, yeah. Literally a week apart.
I just did his podcast couple
of weeks ago. He's a natural,
like when we talk about the
skill set of conversations. Yeah.
He's really good at it. His Dad
was a big time radio host. Yeah.
Oh I didn't know that.
Yeah. Wow. Greg and I did so
many fucking cakes together.
We steal each other's material.
Really? We had a deal cause we both,
neither one of us were really, we really
shouldn't have been working, you know,
we would only like 20 years ago.
More. More. Yeah. Like 89, 88.
Wait, how long have you been doing
it? Since 88. August 27th, 1980 h wow.
And um, so we're coming up on your
anniversary. Yeah, yeah. In 19. Yeah.
In 2018 it will be my 30th
anniversary. Wow. Crazy.
I'm exactly half that. Yeah. Um,
and anyway, um, so Greg and
I would like, would do gigs,
like when we're a year in and we'd
get paid, you know, to go on the road.
And so we had like a deal,
like you could do my material to your
materials were really good friends.
So he's like, dude, you're fucking
material is killing in Connecticut.
And he was like serious, like yeah, I
would tell him no that bit that you do.
I did that and fucking Rhode Island.
But it was like it was
parachutes for you guys. Oh yeah.
We really shouldn't have been working.
I mean,
we're doing comedy a fucking year and
if something went bad it went bad.
You know? Like I'd never recovered.
Never. I mean I can, you know,
you got to have a shit joke and
just bounce back from it. Toto,
if somebody stumbled through something,
you can bounce back from it.
Back then there was no,
there was no recovery.
I remember opening on a bad joke
and just riding that bad way.
Long set. Yeah. You open bed. Yeah. I
didn't have a way to put it back together.
Yeah, you come out stumbling, you just
never get your balance back. Now you open.
If you open bad, you'd be
like, all right. You know,
it's the one place where you
won't work where you want,
where you won't get booked. He's
just like, I'm not going there.
Like where's the Cleveland
Improv? Well, does
they cultivate a bad audience?
Right. That does happen. It's,
you know what the problem is? It's
the same thing that happened, um,
with Miami did with their,
with their club is that they used to like
announce that you can get free tickets
here. So like I remember one time
going there working and I was like,
check out this line. This is awesome.
It's going to be, it's going to be great.
And the guy goes here, here for the
free tickets. So like when you're,
when you cultivate this is free. It
just, it, you know, it's, it's, it's,
that's why there's been so good. It
does. But when you just go like, look,
these are $5 tickets, you're making an
investment in your night in the show.
And that changes it. And I think
Cleveland did a lot of that too.
A lot of like this is free.
It's the worst thing you could ever
do to a show paper it because then the
people just start talking. They don't
give a fuck. It doesn't mean anything to,
they'll get up and leave in
the middle of the show. Yeah.
Nothing invested in it for me. It's
Connecticut. I don't go to Kim. Yeah,
you told me that. You're telling me
can I can suck my dick the whole state.
The whole state. No, no disrespect to
anybody in Connecticut. Disrespect.
No disrespect. I did it like two times
this year. Yeah. Yeah. All those people,
you know, you know where you live. I
did Yukon. I had a great time at Yukon.
I did the college. Yeah. A bunch of
people from somewhere else. Yeah,
just stuck in there.
That's true.
If I can guarantee that they'd bus
people in from New York and Boston,
I'd do a show there.
He would never do the Foxwoods Fox.
Where are you most excited about to
go on the store? I like Texas. Well,
I mean I just,
I like going places where it's fun.
There's something about
Connecticut that's bleak.
There's like a lack of opportunity.
This
is something bleak about it. It's,
it's almost like an illegitimate state.
It's like a highway between Boston and
New York. That's really what it is.
And it always feels like that when
you're there just feels weird.
Like there's a lot, like almost like
there's a sadness that permeates the show.
Even when they laugh.
Like
I love that you hate a place
that much bad sets. They're like,
I hit a lot of places when the cameras
are off, we can talk about them then. Oh,
well Diaz and Ari and I did a show
at Fox woods a few years back and um,
and I told them before I go,
it was like a Monday and a Tuesday
night because they had a comedy club at
Foxwoods
comedy club and restaurant.
I had to put that on my website.
I had a bad,
it's comedy club and restaurant had
called, they make you say an restaurant.
Restaurant. Yeah. And make you make you
on the, on your promos. They're like,
could you fucking say the full name?
Oh my God. I had a bag when there,
I had a bad set. That was great. That
was the last time. And I was like,
never again. I told you guys before,
this is probably going to suck.
And Ari was like,
I knew it was going to suck,
but I didn't know what was going to
saw. I got, yeah, it sucked. It's just,
it's just the people were,
they wouldn't stop heckling,
they were yelling out during Ari set
yelling out during even Diaz is like,
we just shut the fuck up.
Like yelling at someone thrown
out of there and afterwards,
like some of the staff was like,
so what was going on?
And the other thing is
bad thing about people don't realize
about casinos is that there's a,
there's an like this total idea that
it benefits any aspect of the casino to
keep the customer happy regardless
of every other circumstance.
In other words, somebody is
upset at the restaurant, uh,
well let's try to make it right because
they're, they're here at the casino.
We want them to stay happy, keep
getting, they go to a comedy show. Well,
whatever they're doing, it's
fine. It's like, no, no, no,
whatever they're doing is not fun
because this, this is about the show.
But the venues point of
view is this is a gambler.
This is somebody who's
here to spend money.
So we should always acquiesce
to their desires and needs and,
and don't,
don't do anything to upset them.
And you're like that how that works
man. Like this is, this is our show.
My favorite what the Casino Gig.
It's always how they, uh, you know,
you've got the Ding, Ding, Ding, Ding,
Ding. The machine sounds and they're like,
but there's a curtain that separates the
comedy club from the Ding, Ding, Ding.
Denae and you could still hear it like
they actually have a show in Vegas at the
south point. That dirty.
Yeah. Like you're,
you could look out and you see
the casino while you're on stage.
The back of the room.
There's the bar.
I don't want to fucking casinos right
there. Um, it's weird. Can I ask you,
would you ever date your mom?
Uh, definitely not. First of all,
she's older than me. Second
of all, she's my mom. Well,
why I'm your mom and you're my son
and I if falling in love with him.
He says, are you really? I said,
yes, I am. He said, you know what,
I was scared to let you know too.
I am too. Both consenting adults.
If it comes down to it, you know, it's
just like the gays there, there, you know,
as long as they're over 18 everything's
fine. You know what I mean?
The U s wants to gel them for 18 months
with that'll fix it. They got arrested.
They actually got arrested. Oh well
this should definitely arrest them.
There's a fuck if you want to
fuck your mom. That's our point.
I don't care. I don't care at
all. But I think it's at the,
he wants to marry his mom.
There comes the legality is a shit.
She got a tattoo on her face. I
said go for it. Go back to her.
Definitely like relaying that. It
is just like the gays, the same.
Mine is the same, but there's
nothing quite like marrying your mom.
It's very strange though. See
them making out. It's horrendous.
Ever. Get your mom and he said,
what you did your son. I said,
19 years,
you're the best thing that ever happened
to me and I really want to be with the
rest of my life.
Don't be bag of potatoes
Tattoo on her face.
It's just like the gays. Oh, we're
the best thing ever. I asked,
I asked and there's no k in
that. Yeah, that's a tell mom.
There's no doctors that say, I asked
him where's the hurt? Like asked him
fake. It's so, it's so
crazy. It feels like it,
but I think it is real because I read
a followup articles about like getting
arrested and everything. So
what do they do? They tell them,
you got to stop fucking the Gar.
How they do it.
That, yeah, that's true.
But I also feel like if you're fucking
or like you want to get married to your
mom, like you just stay
inside and don't tell him.
Yeah, it's that they're doing this. See,
that's the problem with today's society
is that everybody has to be out and
proud about every stupid fucking thing
they're doing. What happened to you?
A little sense of shame. Keep it inside.
You know, it's fucking weird. Yeah.
It's weird. Yeah. It's
just like what the gays,
the gays,
the gays.
No, no, no, no. There's other gay
people they see that's, it's definitely,
unless you're fucking your dad, it's
different. Well that's different
fantasies.
You do feel guilt or shame around them.
Maybe you've never allowed yourself to
have them because it pink you would be a
horrible person if you ever went there.
So it's all suppressed.
She went on to say that she started to
masturbate and then thought of everyone
in her family and realize the only
one that turned around was her dad.
She thought about her mom and her son
and all these people and she said,
didn't do anything for me.
Dad Did. And it also made me think,
it's just like the gays, you know?
Real quick, where are you with
me? When we were, uh, when I did,
I don't know if you were with me that time
when I did. Um, what's it called, Jim?
When it was opie and Jim
and, uh, we watched that.
Were you with me when we watched the
footage of the guy at the car port,
the guy in the garage, the Asian guy.
Jesus. Which one was it? What? What was,
let me see. Oh, did you
this footage?
It's a car backing into a garage,
like a mechanic shop.
Basically his face while this place he,
does this look familiar or no? Not yet.
I've seen too much. Yeah, that's true.
Did people ask like different,
okay.
Not seen a lot of laughter on
Joe's goes face. I see a lot of
broken
that dude and Ceca.
How concern his friends are.
Some happen. Well, yeah. Look,
look at how fucking cold back. I still
don't hear Joe's laughter, you know?
It's not really a too many injuries.
Injuries to me aren't funny.
What's interesting is let's
keep going with this thread.
Why aren't injuries funny? Just like I
see people get fucked up all the time.
Yeah.
It's called,
that guy's got a broken legs. Broken
hip, like the impact with that,
the cement wall and then the
toolbox and then his legs,
the legs of the soft thing
the legs are going to give.
That's kind of funny though.
The nothing funny about that.
To me. The wait a minute. Wait,
that's interesting.
What did you just say,
Joe? That's how funny to me. Yeah,
me neither because I think we
have empathy or broken legs. Yeah.
His work this out before.
No, I really don't know.
I'm not good with injuries. Really.
Yeah. I always do too many injuries.
Here's my problem. My
God, I've always laughed.
I think it's because of my own fear
of them. Probably on some level.
I've always had a,
like I remember one time
I worked construction in
Florida one summer and one of
the formulas,
like I had a bathtub dropped on my
neck and I started laughing so hard,
like tears running down my face.
He had a bathtub dropped in
his and he had a permanent, uh,
morphine pack's sewn into his insight into
is just drip it on his neck. And I go,
oh Jesus. I just laughed and laughed.
I go to stop laughing. So crazy.
But I mean it's not even
a, it's not a calculated choice
to laugh. It just happens.
That's why I think it's it. It's
cause I, I actually fear it happened.
If it's not calculated, it's just starts
happening. It just started happening.
I can't control myself. I see
so many injuries. That's true.
You've seen people's heads get bashed
in and you to realize I've probably seen
more people fuck people up like physically
and fights then maybe almost anybody
who's ever lived. That's probably
true. Upclose yeah, I've called.
I mean there's probably a few guys that
are closing in on me now. Numbers wise,
other commentators on fights,
but I've commentated thousands of fights.
Yeah.
Think about that.
All the different concussions.
I've seen all the different knockouts.
Now here's the funny thing
is that I really don't,
I don't laugh when I see head trauma.
No, no, it doesn't do it to me.
Like leg trauma does it. Leg
screaming. The screaming is like,
it makes me laugh.
Being crushed by the left Pelvic Steevo
did show me this new guy that he's
working with.
Steve O's like mentoring some young
psycho who's doing a lot of like jackass
style Stansa and this kid put on a
speedo and rode a skateboard off of a
makeshift ramp into a pile of
cactuses. Oh, it was so fucking crazy.
I was watching it. I'm like,
oh my God. Like my whole body.
You know that thing we get when you see
someone about to get in an accident and
like, yeah, tense adrenaline
pumps through your body and like,
it's almost like you feel like sharp
pointers all over your skin. Yeah.
That's how I felt when I saw,
I've watched this kid launches body into
the cactus. No, we saw one last week.
Uh, remember that, that whole thing
where this dude was trying
to do at Jackass and he and
he tied a rope around his
nut sack and tied the other end to a
tree and then ran and jumped. Oh No.
The rip his balls off. Yeah, he die. Well,
I don't know no balls anymore,
man.
It's this,
don't show it to me.
Show it to me.
Uh,
when I came out dip shit when I came out.
Well,
what did you think was going to happen?
I can't even look at that. I
don't like, I can't see like,
that doesn't make me laugh at deputies
freaks me out. But do you think that,
I mean,
this is like a cliche thing to say,
but don't you think that that in some
ways is evolution like that there are,
there's dumb people that will
do dumb things and it's almost,
they're supposed to die or lose their
bill. I mean it's, it's kind of symbolic
that this guy's tying this to his
reproductive organs you're offering.
Maybe it's an unconscious
wish fulfillment.
Like he doesn't want to live to reproduce.
There's something there. I mean, what,
what would be best case scenario there?
It would hurt his balls and they
wouldn't rip off. Yeah, right, right.
He jumped with a rope tie.
Oh Dude.
Oh my God. Oh my God. God.
Okay. All right. All right. So,
oh my God. Oh my God.
Anything else Jean? Far,
far and no, I mean, I wanted to talk
about your morning farts, but that,
you know,
I got it
and mourning for it as opposed to what
evening farts they different. Well,
I'm a real, I don't know if you or
I wake up with lots of noises. No,
just all heart horror game.
I'm a symphony and the music
find that your digestive tract and
everything is working better. Excuse me.
Working better since your diet?
100% yeah.
He used to shit a lot worse
and now it's much better. Yeah.
He used to have like diarrhea every day.
Yeah.
I think he's allergic to
sugar or some reaction
buddy is the one I have. Like
even now, you know, I'll,
I'll be pretty clean for a number
of days or even weeks. I'll be like,
I'm gonna eat this right now and I'll
indulge in something rich in sugar if
fucking never agrees with me. Oh, kills
you. Yeah. You got used to it for a while,
right? Yeah. And now that
you're not used to it,
your body doesn't know what to do with it.
That's what is this.
I actually found that,
um,
in a lot of times what I want is
just like a taste of something. Oh,
he's have a bite and I'll be like, I'm
actually, I don't, I used to go like,
I'll have 70 bytes of that and now it's
like one or two kind of satisfies it.
Yeah. And then I don't feel sick. Isn't
that Zevs stuff? Fucking amazing dude.
I love it. Hate it. She needs it. The uh,
the water guy spit it out
when he was throwing water.
Yeah. Martin Teresa
spit it out and, and uh,
but my theory on it is this though,
as somebody who's like restricting
themselves from sweetness all the time,
it's like an indulgence you can have. Yes.
So it is like, it's, I notice it's a lot,
it's too sweet for a
lot of people's palate,
but you don't know how much sugar there
regularly having other words. For me,
I feel like it's that, uh, it's like the
free cheat. Right? So you have your z via,
you taste sweetness.
Again,
it sounds, it doesn't bother me
even a little, I enjoy the taste.
I feel like it's too synthetic tasting.
That's what bothers me.
It's like I liked the Dr Pepper alike
taste, but yeah, I like a loquat.
I'd rather do that. Oh, those are great.
I love those too because
those are so light. Yeah.
We know they have Zevia water where it's
just a good, the tiniest hint of flavor.
It's more like a loquat. Okay. Right.
Yeah. So they have the cvs soda,
the of v a um, energy drinks
too, which are amazing. Hmm.
Really good. This is so much
better tasting than red bull.
Oh yeah, totally. People,
we get a lot of songs and people send
in songs they make. Do you
know, like somebody made,
let's go water champ that you said into
a song and they do at least tell the
audience so I can have pretty good.
Yeah.
That you're impressed with my water
consumption. You're the water champ champ.
Or as long as I've known you in power,
the water in the water.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go.
Water chaps catchy pounding the water.
Water champ out on the water.
The water.
Does that bother you?
You guys are competitive,
are you guys competitive with everything?
Just where it can you guys competitive
with stand up. Zero personality.
Literally zero. Probably. Why we transfer
it into like water and personalities.
So it's never been like,
this is a real argument but like,
but I mean it was,
it was real when we were arguing
initially about who drinks more water.
I thought it was,
no,
I had a doctor telling me I should
stop drinking so much water use.
What kind of doctor was he? Urologist. He
goes, you're drinking too much. You drink,
drink far less.
You have to remember she's,
she's an exaggerator didn't really
tell you to stop drinking was he goes,
how much are you drinking? And I told
him, he goes, you don't need to do that.
That's a myth. He goes, just drink when
you're thirsty, you're over hydrating.
True Story. Can you over hydrate
though? You can if you go really,
really nuts if you go like look
a radio contest or when we um,
when we did water cut for the weigh ins,
uh,
I mean I don't know exactly what,
I know I didn't feel good but I drank
over a gallon of water like during that
pot.
The last podcast didn't have to pee yet.
I remember that you kept throwing
down the water. We talked about it.
You had like nine or 10 fucking bottles,
but I mean that's not good.
Probably my body was
like so craving water,
but you just wanted to win that
running away show. That was a horrible,
that the two or three days leading up
to those weigh ins were just horrible at
our house.
I mean he was taking hot baths and then
going into the Jacuzzi and drinking
distilled water and then going to Burke
Williams and doing the sauna and then
there was a lot that he was going to die.
Really did it though.
That was what was impressive about it.
It's like you fucking went for like Burt
was kind of pretending to be going for
it, which is really interesting because
you were talking shit to them and I know
you're being comedic,
but you were also being honest,
like this was calling
playing catchup suckers.
You guys want to buy
into that shit. Yeah. He,
he was trying to catch up at the end
or is you had a sustained effort,
a discipline to effort over
long from the jump off.
I knew that that would be the two
ways psychologically that we'd go.
I know from the very beginning that he
had a, you had to deal with his craziness.
Yes.
That was the thing about crazy and I
even talked to him about that and I said,
the crazies going to help you.
I go,
you're going to need more than the
crazy I go, because you're crazy.
He's going to help you,
but your body can only lose so much
weight over a short period of time. Right.
So don't think that, because
Tom's not fucking around. I go,
he's really doing this. So like you can't
just rely on crazy. Yeah. It's like,
I know, I know. I know. I know. I'm all,
I'm only drinking double Tito's and sodas.
So crazy. It's so crazy. So his videos,
he's always so drunk that I worry
about him man. Cause he's like, what,
46 now or something like that. How old
is he? 23. Oh, that's not blow off.
But what's crazy is okay, but
here's the thing, say he's 43.
You can't do that when you're 50. I
agree. I agree. And you meet Kinda Ken,
but you're,
you're going to fall apart.
Well you can't if you have those Mickey
mantle jeans. Yeah. That long form DNA,
long strand DNA. Yeah. You, there comes
a point in time where your body is like,
hey man, you can't do this
every day. I know. It's enough.
He does have an incredible
standing, uh, to, uh,
the, the ability, you know,
like I'm admittedly not a party guy man.
Like if I have a few drinks and I'm 38,
I mean I feel it for days. He has that.
Like, he's just like, what, let's go out.
And I'd be like, dude, like when we,
when you say very graciously sent us to
go watch the calves and warriors play
for, for doing the weight
loss thing, you know, I mean,
we were like drinking in the morning
and I was like, I got to go take a nap.
He was like, I'll go to the bar
too low. And I just, you know, I,
I took a nap and like, I mean, I had
to like really pace myself by the way.
It was whatever came out of that
with Ari. Ari, uh, well as, I mean,
people know now he's, he was
gone for a long time. He, uh,
finally came back from his, uh,
his vision quest and four months,
four months off, I'm going, no, right.
85% of it was to avoid his
debt with you guys. But he, uh,
as long as they just don't have an
email or don't answer her phone,
he said that he did a podcast. He
opened up by saying it was because, uh,
Tom's tastes or so outrageous
though he snacks on caviar.
Yeah. So it's pretty funny. It
was pretty, it was very funny.
His podcast coming back was hilarious.
Very funny.
And he was actually even joking around
that. That was why man. Um, he's like,
he called me, he goes, all right, where
do you, where do you want to go? And I go,
I don't know. He's like, I've
got to fucking do something.
Like I get like a hundred tweets a day.
Like pay you already took care of it,
dude. I, I told him I go, I don't,
there's no, I don't want to go fine.
But he was like, oh take you
somewhere. Well he fucked up when it,
when it happened at the time you're
supposed to step up then. Yeah,
he was trying to figure
it out of it. Yeah. He was
trying to, you know, 0.1, two,
five things shorter. I'm like, all
right man. Yeah. Well what was his, his,
his argument, the BMI.
He was like, he's like,
well BMI wise you're not actually six
feet, you're five and eight tenths.
So your actual BMI to get out of that,
it had to be if you were an inch taller
or no, they said 25 pounds. Right. Dude,
it was kind of write it down on
paper with him. I know, I know.
I learned my lesson. There's
some other crazy shit he
say. No, I'll tell you later.
Dump dump
now.
All right, we should, we should,
we should wrap this up. So, um,
is there anything else you have? Okay. All
right. Uh, thank you for coming Joe. Yeah,
my pleasure.
We'll do this.
We do this run down at the top
of dates but just so you know,
you go to Joe rogan.net/tour he's doing,
you better hop on it cause you added all
these shows and those are going to go
quick. I have a second shows to like
a lot of places are going to be nuts.
Here's the song,
um,
how I glass by young Patriot on our
way out. Thanks a lot for coming, man.
Pleasure.
Thanks for having me.
Fossil ranch baby
budget married.
My Dad
ain't got no temple
has this double Bob Ross.
Do you know how much money
I've got? A really bad, bad got
a really bad bite come does take,
just slip it
damn moose ride on his ass.
Shit.
Yeah.